AND WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY
SELECT COMMITTEE ON HEALTH I
WANNA CALL THIS HEARING TO
ORDER. HI THIS IS ABOUT THE
IMPACT OF GOT. MENTAL HEALTH.
THE FOR WANT TO TALK BRIEFLY.
WHY WE ARE HOLDING THE- A
VIOLENCE HAS A RIPPLING EFFECT
ON OUR CHILDREN'S LIVES. THE
LAST WELL TO IT. WE KNOW THE
GUN VIOLENCE IS AN UNDERLYING
CAUSE OF THESE IS THE RESEARCH
ON THIS IS AMPLE AND WILL
MENTION. TODAY WE'RE HERE FROM
A NATIONAL AND LOCAL ADVOCATES
THE COP. WORK DIRECTLY WITH OUR
USE IN THEIR COMMUNITIES AS
FOLKS WHO EXPERIENCE AND
VIOLENCE WE ALL HAVE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING BETWEEN. XIN OF
GUN VIOLENCE IN. OUR MENTAL
HEALTH AND WE NEED TO HEAR FROM
PEOPLE. I SAW THE SEVEN. YOUR
FOR TODAY'S FIND SOME SOLUTIONS
TO AN EVER PROBLEM EVER SINCE I
AM WORKING ON REALLY EIGHT
BILLION. COME TO THIS ISSUE OF
FOR DEEPLY PERSONAL REASONS- MY
WAS GABBY GIVE OTHERS
LEGISLATIVE. THROUGH THAT
PROCESS. TOWN STARTED A GIFT
WHICH DOESN'T HAVE IT THE WORK
AND DIFFERENT REPRESENTED ON
THE PANEL TODAY THERE ARE MANY
OTHER GROUPS ORGANIZATIONS FOR
HERE WHO WILL SPEAK AND FOLKS
WHO ACTED ON SO WE'RE LOOKING
FOR A FRUITFUL CONVERSATION- TO
ALSO BE GUIDED BY ACADEMICS AND
RESEARCHERS. IN TIME WORKING
THIS. THEY SAID. COME UP WITH
SOLUTIONS THAT I CAN TAKE BACK
WITH ME TO. ARE DIRECTLY. SO
THAT WE CAN AND- I WANT TO
PANELISTS. COMING THE WONDERFUL
THE FULL STEVE OAKLAND FOR
THOSE OF YOU THAT HAVE TRAVELED
MUCH FOR THE MONNING. I TO
ENSURE. THAT OUR PANELISTS KEEP
THEIR. ONCE OR I KNOW THAT'S
NOT A LOT OF TIME BUT WE HAVE A
LOT OF. FROM TODAY. KEEPER DEAN
WHO'S RIGHT THERE RAISE YOUR
HAND. WILL RAISE THE AT THE ONE
MINUTE MARK AND THEN A FINAL.
WHEN TIME IS UP. SPEAKERS TO
GET THROUGH SO THAT I ASK THAT
YOU PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL ABOUT
YOUR A LOT OF TIME. AND MOST
CRITICALLY WE. WILL ALSO HAVE
TIME FOR COMMENT- NO. I FIRST.
LIKE TO. INVITE OUR PANEL TO
COME UP. FIRST SAID A PANELIST
THE FOLLOWING. NATIONAL AT
SUPER SPEED YOU CAN IN AMERICA
BUT FIRST HAS TO BEGIN WITH OUR
SPEAKERS. BASE OF THE ISSUE.
I'D LIKE HOW SOMEONE HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS GREGORY HAMPTON
TO KICK OFF OUR FIRST. WILL
BEGIN GREEN AS WE MOVE ALONG
SPEAKERS PLEASE INTRODUCED AS
YOU BEGIN- AS YOU BEGIN YOUR
TESTIMONY GREAT FLOOR IS NOW
YOUR- THANK YOU. WHO IS VERY
HANDSOME I GO TO CAST MY SCHOOL
OUR TEAM HERE. TWENTY YEARS OLD.
I AM A WITH NATION CORTINES
ARGUED THE ORGANIZES UTILIZED.
AS I SAY ABOUT GUN VIOLENCE IS
THAT IS A VERY. DEMI DOES. THE
NEIGHBORHOOD. I FEEL LIKE THAT
A BIG PROBLEM AND THAT IS WHY
JOINT TEENS ON TARGET IT'S
AFFECTED ME IN A BIG WAY NOW
LIKE OF ALL WELL I HEAR GUNSHOT
AND I JUST SIT DOWN LIKE I'VE
LOST FAMILY MEMBERS. PART OF
GUN VIOLENCE I WILL JOIN GAINES
DONE A LOT OF THINGS. BEFORE
THE TEENS ON TARGET TO LIKE
THAT I. OUR LEGAL I DIDN'T HAVE
NO ONE TO LOOK UP TO YOU I WILL
ALWAYS BY MASS. AND SO I HAD
THERE'S ONE FRIEND I WAS SAYING
AND THEN HE ONE DAY HE CAME UP
TO ME AND HE WAS LIKE. GREG YOU
WANT TO COME WHERE. IT ALLOWS
THINGS LIKE A LOT OF HIM AND HE
WENT TO GO WITH THE KNOWN GANG
MEMBER APART CLING AND HE
STOPPED DEAD START TALKING HE
STARTED A GIVE ME THAT THESE
IDEAS TO JOIN A GANG IN MY MIND
I'M LIKE. THIS ROTANA GO DOWN
THIS IS NOT GOING TO DO. I LEFT
IT WASN'T. EVEN KNOWS. WHAT
AFTER. I'VE BEEN AT THE TOP HIM
DOWN. TO MEET THE GREAT AYE AYE
WHY. THE BENEFITS TO JOIN ALLEN
BE ALONE. LIKE THAT BUT MY MIND
I THAT THAT'S NOT THE ROLE
NOBODY THOUGHT OUT THAT'S NOT
WHAT I WANT TO DO THAT'S NOT
THE TYPE OF. DOWN TO FIX. THIS
NINE GREAT. I JOIN TEENS ON
TARGET WE ARE WE'RE ABOUT. DO
IS WE GO TO MAY. BE TWO YOUNGER
KIDS ABOUT GUN VIOLENCE YOUNG
BLIX USES GO BY. THE VOTE OUR
POVERTY LACK OF POSSIBLE MY
EASY ACT. JONES ALCOHOL FEAR
AND THE. HOW TO THE MIDDLE OF
THIS. WE TALKED TO THEM CLOSER.
ROBIN NOT WOULD. HAVE TO DO
WHAT THEY WANTED NOT WHAT THEY
SHOULD. GOING ALL. HEARING
GOING UP FOR THE FOR THE MEMBER
THEN WE WILL GIVE THEIR ALL
BREAK DEVELOP ALL THEY HAVE
THEIR OWN MODERNIZE THEM I KNOW
JOIN A GANG AND CARRYING A GUN
IN IF YOU CARRY A GUN YOUR SKI
BECAUSE IF YOU CARRY MORE
LIKELY TO GET SHOT YOU'RE MORE
LIKELY TO BE A TARGET OR LIKE
WE- YOU KNOW DO THINGS THAT YOU.
DO SO WHAT. I GO TO MOVE. IS
BASICALLY. TO PEOPLE AND HOW TO
DO THE THINGS I DO IS TO COME
OUT TALK TO THE GUYS AND GO OUT.
THE. BASICALLY GIVE MYSELF THEN
OTHER PEOPLE POINT WHAT DID WE-
WILL MY WHAT IMPACT THEY MEET
THE JOINT IN ON TARGET WOULD
MARK IS GOING. ALSO GOT THAT.
SO YOU PROBABLY ALL WONDER.
READ MY NAME WHY I AM. WE KNOW
IT'S A SMALL TOWN TWENTY MILES
NORTH OF MIAMI WHO'S GOT A THAT
DON'T KNOW WHAT'S HAND BECAME
WORLD FAMOUS FOR STARTING A
MASSIVE. GUN CONTROL MOVEMENT.
AS AS A PROBLEM THAT CAN THAT
MOVEMENT TO YOU KNOW WAS
ADVOCATING FOR THE CHANGE OF MY
PEERS AND I WERE. YOU KNOW ON
TV EVERYDAY TALKING. HEY BRO
WE'VE SHORTENED ONE AT AS
MENTAL. WE WEREN'T PUTTING EGGS
IN. OF MENTAL HEALTH. I JUST.
NONPROFIT MY SAY RIGHT WHAT I'M
GONNA DO IS IMPLEMENT ALL THREE
SCHOOLS. AND. MY YOUR I THINK I
WAS I'M A PRETTY TALL ORDER.
YEAR OLD KID WHO DOESN'T EVEN
KNOW. I'M MUCH OF ANYTHING
REALLY. AT THE TIME I SAID. SO.
ONE OF THE FIRST PEOPLE TO
REACH OUT TO WAS THE PRINCE
NORTH BY. HE GOT BACK TO ME AND
DINNER AND HE ME I HIS MENTAL.
ONE AFTER. ON THEIR PRICES IN.
AND A BETTER SITUATION I WAS
FEELING. ANY KIND OF NEGATIVE
WHAT A OR IF I. HAD A NEGATIVE
SELF TALK GOING ON. YES MY
FRIENDS SAY HEY I DO YOU. I'VE.
OKAY WILL HELP BRING IN BREA-
INTO THE NIGHT I TOLD I DO KIND
OF PRACTICES- THAT MY
CURRICULUM THE COMES FROM JACK
THE PRINCE NORWAY NO HAS TO
OFFER AND SO. WHAT. GIVE THEM
IS THE DIRECTION SIZE BASICALLY
WITH THIS YOU SEE. YOU START
YOURSELF WHEN YOU. WHEN YOU SAY.
YOU BASED CONFIRM THE GOOD THAT
YOU WANT TO ACHIEVE IN YOUR
LIFE SO WITH THAT WANT TO
BECOME. PRESIDENT ST STE ONE UP.
IT YOURSELF EVERY MORNING AND
THIS. WELL YOU'LL GET.
ULTIMATELY BRING YOU ATTENTION
UNITS BUT I'M VERY. IF YOU GIVE
YOU INSPIRE PEOPLE TO ACHIEVE
CERTAIN GOALS THIS. ATTAIN
ANYTHING AND PART OF IT
ANYTHING IS A BELIEVE THAT YOU
CAN. SO HOW THIS REALLY TO GUN
VIOLENCE IS WHEN YOU HAVE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE BEING
TRAUMATIZED DAILY BASIS. BUT
THIS IF YOU FEEL LIKE. MUSIC HE
DIDN'T HAVE TO PAIN SO. THANK
YOU MASLOW HIERARCHY WELL
YOU'RE ALWAYS IN A CONSTANT
FIVE. THESE RESOURCES TO PICK
THEM UP AT SEA TO SURVIVAL TO
BE ABLE TO. THE TOOLS THEY NEED
TO EMPOWER THEMSELVES TO DO
BETTER AND TO LIVE A BETTER
LIFE. AND SO I GOT THIRTY
SECONDS LEFT AND NOW BUT.
PEOPLE ALWAYS ASK ME IS HOW
QUANTIFY IT'S GREAT TO TALK
THIS TALK OKAY WELL I'M GONNA
EMPOWER PEOPLE BUT HOW DOES IT.
WORK HOW DO WE KNOW THAT. AS I
SAID OKAY. WE'RE GOING TO DO IS
WITH AMERITECH COMPANY. WE'RE
PARTNER WITH THAT NUMBER TO
COMPANY CALLED BRAIN BECAUSE
THAT'S BEEN DOING SOME WORK IN
CHIN. AND YOU KNOW THEY
BASICALLY. LIST THIS IS ARMEN
FOLK. MEASURE HOW THAT AFFECTS
STUDENTS FOUND WAS EXERCISE
THAT THEY THEY THEMSELVES ARE
USED IN MY PROFESSORS DOUBLE
STUDENT EMMA CAPABILITY. AND
NOT ONLY THAT BUT IMPROVES
OVERALL. YOU KNOW WELL THAT IT
SO I FIGURED THAT SINCE WE HAVE
THIS THING THAT. TO WORK. AND
COMMUNITIES WITH THE RESOURCES
THAT ALLOW SEE. HOW IT WORKS
CAN USE THAT THE WAR. YOU CHECK
THE FABRIC OF THIS NATION IN
TERMS OF VIOLENCE. GET OUT
EVERYBODY MY NAME MY LIVELY
SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY AGAIN FOR
THE CENTER TO PREVENT. RIGHT
ACTOR UNITY VIOLENCE INITIATIVE
SO I WANTED TO JUST A LITTLE
BIT OF SORT OF CONTACTS SETTING
AND TAKE A LOOK AT THIS FROM A
SORT OF. A NATIONAL PERSPECTIVE
I THINK IT'S A SURPRISE TO
ANYONE THAT GUN VIOLENCE OUT OF
CONTROL IN THE STATE YOU CAN
OTHER HIGH INCOME COUNTRIES
WORLD. ANYTHING PEOPLE ARE
PARTICULARLY IMPACTED BY THIS
DEMI. THESE ARE THE THIRD CAUSE
OF DEATH FOR GUN PEOPLE FOR
GOOD FOR YOUNG PEOPLE IN THE
UNITED STATES. WHICH I THINK IS
PRETTY STAGGERING AND AT THIS
POINT ALMOST A 100% OF OUR KIDS
IN PUBLIC SCHOOL ARE DISSIPATE.
IN ACT SHOOTER DRILLS WITH TO
BE EXTREMELY A LOT. IT ALSO
LOCKS. ROUGHLY A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE UNDER THE
AGE OF EIGHT SINCE YOUR TWO
THOUSAND AND THIS WHICH IS JUST
A STAGGERING NUMBER LIVES CUT
SHORT. WE KNOW FROM RESEARCH
ANALYTICS. THE GUN. IN EXPOSURE
TO VIOLENCE LINKED TO DRAMA TO
PTSD AND TO. TERM AND LONG TERM
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
IMPACTS. SO WHAT HELPS EXPLAIN
THIS DEVASTATING EPIDEMIC WIDE
KNIGHTED STATES DIFFERENT FROM
OTHER DEVELOPED HIGH INCOME
NATIONS IN THE WORLD. THE
ANSWER IS THE ACCESS TO
FIREARMS THAT JUST TODAY ARE
VERY RECENTLY THE A TF RELEASED.
NEW ESTIMATES SHOWING THAT
THERE ARE MORE THAN FOUR.
MILLION. ARMS AND SIT IN HERE
TO THE UNITED STATES THAT'S
MORE THAN ONE. FOR EVERY MAN
WOMAN OUT IN THIS COUNTRY. AND
WE COMBINED THAT IN THIS
COUNTRY WITH EXTREMELY WEAK GUN
LAWS GUN REGULATION OF THE
FEDERAL LEVEL AT THE STATE
LEVEL ONE OF THE THINGS THE
GIFFORDS IS WE GRADY TO THE
STATES BASED ON THE STRENGTH OR
WEAKNESS OF. POLICY IS IT TRUE
THAT THAT THE MAJORITY. OF NF
THREE DOING VERY LATE FALL TO
ADDRESS THAT PARTICULAR
PROBLEM. CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY
HAS THE NATION'S GUN LAWS. IN
RECENT DECADES THAT HAS HELPED
US TO LARGE. USE OUR GOT IT
THEN WE CURRENTLY HAVE ONE OF
THE LOWEST GUN SUICIDE RATE IN
THE NATION AND OUR GUN HOMICIDE
RATE HAS BEEN REDUCED
DRAMATICALLY AS WELL. WE STILL
HAVE A LOT OF WORK LEFT.
CALIFORNIA AND I HIGHLIGHT
INTERPERSONAL MY COMMENTS
BECAUSE THAT PARTICULARLY
IMPACTS ON PEOPLE THE YOUNG
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND ALTHOUGH
MASS SHOOTINGS DENOMINATOR
NATIONAL CONVERSATION AND POP
THE HEADLINES IN OUR COUNTRY IT
IS DAILY GOTTEN VIOLENT.
HEARING FOR INDIA AND AROUND
THE COUNTRY THAT. THREE OF SH.
AND THIS ONE JUST IS COMMUNITY
BLUR AND IS OFTEN COMMITTED BY
PEOPLE CELEBS HAVE BEEN THE
VICTIM. FOUR TIMES IN THEIR
LIFE. PEOPLE HURT PEOPLE OUR
POLICY THINK HOW. LIKE THAT THE
GOOD NEWS IS. HELP SHOW ME KLAY
REDUCED RATES ISLANDS IN OUR
CITIES AND A RELIC. TIME.
EXAMPLES COME FROM HERE GLENN
AND ALSO IN THE AREA. WHERE
PROGRAMS LIKE ADVANCE PEACE ARE
WORKING IN IT AND WHERE THOSE
AT HIGHEST RISK GIVEN. AFTER
PROVIDING MENTAL HEALTH
COUNSELLING AND CAUGHT INTO
BEHAVIORAL THERAPY. IS YOUR
HIGH INVOLVEMENT WITH VIOLENCE
THIS YEAR DIFFERENCE IN A WHOLE
ORGANIZATION. LEADERSHIP SEMI
AWAKE TO PUSH FOR CALIFORNIA
TOO DRAMATIC INCREASE OUR
INVESTMENT IN THE CALIFORNIA
VIOLENCE INTERVENTION
PREVENTION PROGRAM ALSO NOW.
WHICH IS WHERE ONE OF THE FEW
STATES IN THE COUNTRY THE
PROVIDING RESOURCES FOR CITY
THE SCALE TYPE OF INTERVENTION
PROGRAMS THAT ARE HAVING SUCH
HUGE IMPACT. SO WE CAN. MAKE A
BIG DIFFERENCE IN THE COMING
YEAR. TO COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE. YOU TO
HAVE THAT WAS WHEN YOU
APPROPRIATION WE STEP
DIRECTIONS TO CONTINUE THAT
WORK SO I JUST WRAP UP I THINK
WOULD BE BACK WITH THE LEAD
JUST AGAIN AND THE GOVERNOR
AGAIN HERE TO INSIST THAT THE
SPENDING CONTINUE AT THAT AND
INCREASE OVER TIME AND THAT WE
ARE VERY SERIOUS ABOUT THING.
USING AN ENDING HOMICIDE GUN
HOMICIDE IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
YOU PUTTING OUR MONEY WHERE OUR
MOUTH IS IN INVESTING THOSE
RESOURCES WILL THAT MAKE THE
BIGGEST DIFFERENCE SO AND THERE
THANK. I'M ON THE PILL AND
BOUGHT A NEW. POINT AFTER AND
THEN FOR THE CAMPAIGN. HAPPILY
THE FROM OTHERS IN CHARGE ON.
PUBLISHED. HELLO CHALLENGING
THIS IS. BECAUSE IT AFFECTED ME
IN SOME WAYS FIRST OF I LOST MY
YOUNGEST SON TO GO I'M AS IN
NINETY SIX WALLET TO INTEGRATE
TO PARTY. AND TWO PEOPLE. THE
NEW FRIENDS OF HIS. CAME TO THE
PARTY ONE HAD THE OTHER ONES
JORI ALL ROUNDER WANTED IT AND
THE OTHER ONE WHO. AS YOU WANT
TO GIVE IT TIME SOUL THE
MODIFIER TO RESOLVE. AND AWAY
FROM THE BECAUSE THEY KNEW THAT
YOUNG MAN CARRY ON SO HE THEY
WONDERED WHY IT'S HARD TO GET
HURT AT THAT TIME. YOU KNOW IN
THE AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY
LATINO COMMUTE IS GONE
EVERYWHERE BECAUSE IT WAS THE
CRACK COCAINE EPIDEMIC AND THE
DRUG. THE WALL WELL- IN OUR IN
OUR NATION SO. THE YOUNG MAN
THAT MY SON DID HAVE SOME-
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES IT WAS. HE
DIDN'T KNOW WE HAD. HELLO SOREN
NEVER UNTIL HE BECAME
INCARCERATED NOT. AN ELSE
BIPOLAR HOWEVER AND HE SOME
TALK TIME AND HE MIGHT. I'M SO.
IT GIVES HIM AND MYSELF BEING
IN THE MIDDLE OF TRYING TO BE
THE PEACEMAKER THE MAN. IT
ESCALATED AND YOU KNOW WHAT
EACH OTHER ON THE MAN PULLED
HIS PULLED A GUN SHOP TIMES MY
SON DIED A MAINLY ON SCENE.
MYSELF FOR YOURSELF. I HAVE
BEEN JULY TWENTY TWO NINETY SIX.
THE NEXT DAY JULY EIGHTY WAS MY
SIX YEAR OLD GRANDSON'S BIRTH.
TO BE THE ONE TO TELL HIM ABOUT
HIS THAT. I COULDN'T TELL AND
EXAM YOU'LL- AND DIE AND- THAT.
A TRADE THINGS TO MY FAMILY- HE
TAKEN TO THAT IS. EVERY FAMILY
ADDICTED TO THIS IS MY CELL DID
AS WELL BECAUSE OF THE ANGER IN
THE BUSINESS AND FRUSTRATE NOT
GETTING HELP FROM ANYONE
COLONEL JUSTICES ARE ANYWHERE
AND SO ON IN THIS BECAUSE I
KNOW THAT THEY'RE- GOING TO BE.
ONE. I'M IN IT TO WIN IT AND
NOT STOP WE WERE YELLING AND
SCREAMING OF THIS OVER TWENTY
YEARS AGO HE'S BEEN GONE-
BEFORE THE SCHOOLS TO DO FOR
ALL THOSE. THINGS THAT HAD
HAPPENED AND I'LL GO ON
COUNTRY- THEM. IF YOU DON'T DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THIS PROBLEM
NOW IS GOING TO SPREAD IT'S
GOING TO BECOME AN EPIDEMIC. DO
YOU THINK NOR SO THEY IGNORE
LOOK WHERE WE ARE TODAY SO I'M
HERE BECAUSE OF THAT. AND TO
SEE A STOP KILLING THE HIP. HEY
MY NAME IS ERIC RICE I AM ALSO
SENDING BRADY IN NATIONAL
ACCOUNTS PREVENTION
ORGANIZATION I'M AT THE OPEN
PART. OF OUR THANK. IF I FOCUS
ON HELLO. TO OUR COMMUNITY
BECAUSE- EQUALLY YEAH. LIKELY
TO BE SHOT THAN THEIR PEERS IN
OTHER DEVELOPED NATIONS. IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN CALIFORNIA THE
SEVENTEENTH HIGHEST HOMICIDE
RATE FOR AGES TEN TO TWENTY
FOUR ON AVERAGE. INTERPRETING
FOURNET. EIGHTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
TO TWENTY. IT IS LIKELY. EVEN
IN A DATE WITH SOME OF THE
STRONGEST GUN LAWS IN THE
COUNTRY GUN VIOLENCE REMAINS AN
EPIDEMIC SPECIALLY FOR YOUTH OF
COLOR. NO PART WAS A MAJOR
TURNING POINT IN THE GUT
WRENCHING. HOWEVER IN THE AIR
AFTER PARKLAND ALAMEDA COUNTY
HAVE THE SECOND HIGHEST RATE DO
YOU THINK THIS. TO TAKE A
MOMENT. JOHNSON WHO HAS
GRACIOUSLY ALLOWED ME TO SHARE
HIS STORY TODAY. AT FOUR OH
HOUSE WAS OAKLAND ON A SUNDAY
MORNING PUMP MISLEAD OR. HE
WORE SOMEWHAT WHEN THE SHOOTER
GAME BUT THE SCARS OF THAT DATE
FROM SEARS. REMEMBER LYING ON
THE GROUND. AS HE WAITED FOR
OPD. HEALING CIRCLES. FOR HIS
CONTINUED RECOVERY HAS HIS NAME
HE SHARES SPOKE OF. HE AND HIS
WIFE KEEP BEING IN THE LIFE
WOULD NEVER BE AS HE AND A
SPOT. AT THE TIME IN BED. AS A
REMINDER. US YOUTH EVEN WE HAVE
THIS INSTANT. I CITIES CONTINUE
TO REDUCE CHEATING SIMILAR TO
THE ONE CASE. THE RATE OF TEEN
SUICIDE IS PAYING SUICIDE IS
THE SECOND LEADING CAUSE OF
DEATH FOR TEN TO. THERE'S SOME
RELATIONS ARE MORE VULNERABLE
THAN OTHER OF FOR EXAMPLE THE
LGBTQ YOUTH. ARE UP TO FOUR
TIMES. RISING RATE OF SUICIDE
IN. SAM REGARD THE REASON.
MICHAEL SIEGEL OF DIVERSITY IS
KIND OF ONE THING HOW HOUSEHOLD
GUN. WAS THE SINGLE GUESS
PROTECTOR OF YOUTH SUICIDE RATE
IN ANY STATE. IT'S A COMPANY IS
A PUBLIC HEALTH. BUT THERE ARE
WAYS TO REDUCE HARM. ACCESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH THIS FRIENDLY
SPACE. AND TO ABILITY OF GUNS
BECAUSE A PROGRESSION TO MORE.
ACCESS. AND AVAILABILITY AND
HOMES AND COMMUNITIES FOR YOU.
AND EVERYONE HI MY NAME IS
CRYSTAL LOPILATO AND I'M A WITH.
IN MY PROFESSIONAL LIFE I'M
BERNARD A BUSY PLAYING A LOT
FOR HIM BUT A START DURING MY
TIME WITH MOM AND ACTION A FEW
YEARS AGO. BECAUSE I COULDNT
SIDELINES AND MORE AS OUR GUN
VIOLENCE EPIDEMIC. A LOT OF
ROLE. MIGHT TURN THREE WHICH
MEANS I SPEND EVERY NIGHT CHECK
FOR HER BACK BUT IN IN THE CAR
I SAID. THOSE BEARS AND IF YOU
GO RIGHT AFTER THE SHOOTING AT
A HIGH ON ST RITA DAUGHTER
STARTED ASKING ME TO CHECK FOR
BAD GUYS TO. THE NEXT NIGHT
ASKED ME IF THE PIGGY AMHERST.
SCARED BECAUSE MAYBE THERE WAS
A BAD GUY WHO WAS IT HIM. NEVER
SAY THAT BUT THOSE ARE THE
WORDS SHE SAID AND- OF COURSE
THE BEDTIME STORY HAD NOTHING
TO DO WITH GOD THE BAD GUYS WE
DON'T TALK ABOUT THOSE TOPICS
WITH HER YET. WE ARE. THREE AND
SHE GOES TO BOTH AND NOW VERY
REAL FEARS ABOUT HAD GUYS GUNS.
BEING MADE
. AIRED OUR FESTIVAL.
NOR THAT MANY COMMUNITIES HAVE
TO FOR THEIR SAFETY JUST
TALKING TO AND FROM SCHOOL. THE
WEATHER IN THIS PANEL AND
BECAUSE WE CANNOT NUMBER. THEY
HAVE THOSE WORRIES. SO HERE'S
WHAT WE KNOW OF THE GUN IS
IMPACTING OUR- HEALTH. FIRST WE
KNOW THE KIDS ARE DYING.
IMPOSSIBLE TO IT. AT AIR
COMMENCED FOREMEN AVERAGE OF
TWO OF THE SIX CHILDREN AND
TEENS AGES YOUR- DIVE. PERCENT
OF THESE DEATHS ARE HOME.
FIREARMS ARE THE SECOND LEADING
TO DEATH CHILDREN AND TEENS IN
CALIFORNIA. AND BLACK CHILDREN
AND TEENS IN CALIFORNIA SO. HE
IS A WHITE PEERS TO DIE BY GUN.
WE KNOW THAT THE IMPACT OF
VIOLENCE IS BEYOND FATALITIES
IN PHYSICAL AND- CHILDREN ARE
HARMED IN NEW. CITY. EXPOSED TO
VIOLENT CRIME IF YOU ARE MORE
LIKELY TO SUFFER PRESSURE
ETIENNE PTS. OR TWO THEN
VIOLENTLY HERE AND TO ENGAGE IN
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY. EXPOSURE TO
COMMUNITY FUN BUT. INCLUDING
WITNESSING SHOOTING GUNS MAKES
IT HARDER FOR CHILDREN TO
SUCCEED IN SCHOOL. HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS WHO HAVE BEEN EXPOSED
TO HAVE LOWER TEST SCORES AND
LOWER RATES OF HIGH SCHOOL GRAD
CHIN. MOMS DEMAND ACTION IT ON
FOR GUN SAFETY HAVE IDENTIFIED
SEVERAL WAYS THE STATE CAN TAKE
ACTION TO SOLVE THIS. INVESTING
USED. VIOLENCE INTERVENTION
PROGRAMS VEHICLE FOR DOING THAT.
ID AND FURTHER INVESTMENT AND
TELL THE COW THAT AREA. TO
SUPPORT SCHOOL IMPLEMENTING
THREAT ASSESSMENT. WITH AN
EMPHASIS ON TECHNIQUES NOT
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT
STUDENTS OF COLOR THIS DOESN'T
PROGRAMS LIKE THE VIRGINIA
STUDENT THREAT ASSESSMENT GUIDE.
SCHOOLS THAT CAN. HELP THEY
NEED. THREE THIS IS MY LAST ONE.
INVESTORS PROGRAMS THAT
ENCOURAGE PARENTS AND FAMILIES
TO PRACTICE SAFE STORAGE IF THE
LOT OF FOREIGN GONNA LIKE OURS
ARE. DATE TO EDUCATE FAMILIES
ABOUT IT BUT STATES OF FRONT
HAVE A HIGH IMPACT IN KEEPING
GUNS OUT OF THE HANDS CHILDREN
GAMES. IF. THANK YOU SOMETHING
MEMBER WHICH FOR HAVING ME GOOD
EVENING EVERYONE MY NAME IS
ALEX WALKER GRIFFIN AND I AM
THE NORTHERN CAL POLITICAL
DIRECTOR FOR MARCH FOR OUR
LIVES AS WE'VE SEEN THE PAST
FEW YEARS GOT BOUNCED NOT
DISCRIMINATE IN THE PAST THERE
BEEN A HUNDRED EIGHTY SCHOOL
SHOULD NATIONWIDE CALIFORNIA'S
OVER TWO THOUSAND HOMICIDES
WORKED OUT AND THREE THOUSAND
OR MORE FIREARM DEATHS. EVERY
YEAR. GUN BOUNCES. OF THOSE WHO
YEAH ISRAELI MENTION BUT POLICE
SHOOTINGS IS ALSO A FORM OF GUN
VIOLENCE IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN ON ONE THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR AMERICANS
WERE. POLICE BLACK AND BROWN
ARE SUPPOSED TO. ONCE IN A
WHILE APART INSTITUTE IS RACISM
AND UNDER INVESTMENTS. WHAT.
BLACK AND BROWN TEENS ARE
FOURTEEN TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
DIE FROM TO FIREARMS WHITE. AND
OFTEN TIMES IN THESE
NEIGHBORHOODS WE. SEE ACCESS
FOR STUDENTS TO TALK TO A
COUNSELOR TO TALK TO SOMEONE
REESE SAYS THAT. THEY ARE.
PRISON AND ALL THE INMATES AT.
I WAS. I AM THE SAME
CONVERSATION REPEATED OVER AND
OVER MIND YOU EVERY. SINGLE ONE
OF THESE MEN WERE IN FOR MURDER
THEY- MIGHT HAVE A RESOURCE.
FOR ME TO ME TO TALK TO
ACCOUNTS. AS WE SAID GOOD
BALANCE IS DOESN'T SCREAMING AT.
FOR YOUR WRITING WE DO HAVE
CONSIDERABLY LOW GUN VIOLENCE
CAN FIRST HOURS IN A PLACE OUR
SON WITH. IN. TWO THOUSAND TO
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THIRTY
MURDER. WE MAY BY THE AND
REMEMBER 54% OF THOSE MURDERS
WERE COMMITTED A GUN THE MORE
TROUBLE I'VE SEEN WE REACHED A
COMPLETE PEACE PLAN AND IS THAT
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE BACK IN
THE STATE AND WE'RE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO WORK WITH ANY MEMBER
WAKES IS HAVE TRAUMAS MENTAL
HEALTH FOR SPIDERS COME TO YOUR
HOUSE TO MAKE SURE IT'S GREAT
WILL. OFTEN TIMES THE POLICE
SHOW UP THEY CAN CREATE. WE
NEEDED. TO INVESTMENT INTO MORE
BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITIES
SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY NEED IT THE
MOST. I'M GONNA BE QUITE HONEST
WITH YOU WHAT WE DO SEE WHY
PEOPLE IN A- PREPOSTEROUS
SITUATION WE LOOK AROUND
CALIFORNIA. IF YOU DO GO TO THE
REAL AREA. THEN THREE WE NEED
MORE BEST THE L. G. B. T.
EIGHTY EIGHT SOME QUITE
ALARMING WHEN. RATES GAVE A LOT
OF THE VIOLENCE THAT HAPPENS
THIS GAME IN. THE SITE. DOWN
HOW I FOUND OUT BECAUSE I. I
TEXTED ON. ONE HAND. AND HIS
BROTHER BEAT ME UP ON FACEBOOK
SAYING. HE PASSED AWAY SO GOING
ON. ISSUE AND I HOPE WE CAN
FIND SOME SOLUTION TO THAT
THANK YOU. ONE THANK THE
PANELISTS I'M FOR THE- TIONS UP
MADDY THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
SHARING THE STORY OF AN AND
I'VE MY HEART GOES OUT TO AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU. I'M WITH
US BECAUSE I THINK WE HAVE TO
KEEP THOSE IN MIND AS WE DO
THIS WORK THAT YOU DO THAT
EVERY SINGLE DAY- I BELIEVE YOU
MENTIONED THAT- SEE. YOU SOUGHT
SOME PAPER HELP. BUT THE TRUCK.
GRANTS AND HOW DID YOU FIND
THAT US HASN'T DEAL LIKE THOSE
TYPES OF ACCESS TO THOSE
RESOURCES FOR YOUR GRANDSON
WERE AVAIL. PRACTICE AND YOU
FEEL YOU HAD ALL THAT YOU
NEEDED IN THAT MOMENT WELL I
WAS X. ON YOU KNOW FROM. FROM
WHAT HAPPENS FOR HIM NOT IS IT
BLUE. HIS WHOLE. WE MAKE IN
PAPER. SAYING HE'S GOING TO GET
THE PERSON WHO DID THE SERVICE.
YOU KNOW CONSTANTLY NO. AND WHY
IS IT THAT WAS IT I WOULD
SOMEONE WANT TO KILL HIM. SIX
YEARS OLD AND I. THANK HIM AND
I WANT THAT TO. ALL I NEED HIM
ALL SO I SOUGHT HELP US. HELP A
CHILD PSYCHOLOGIST. I TALKED TO
THE TEAM BECAUSE THIS SCHOOL
THAT TIME THERE WAS NOTHING
AVAILABLE THERE WAS NO- AS WE
HAVE NOW BECAUSE OF THE WORK
WE'VE DONE. WE HAVE HELP
CENTERS HELP RESOURCE CENTER
AND THEIR- WE DON'T HAVE THAT
BACK THEN. IT IS THAT NOBODY.
YOU KNOW HOW DOES HOW. TOM
ALMOST NO VIOLENCE AND SO- YEAH
I THOUGHT FOR HIM SO I GOT HELP
TALK TO MY GRANDSON ON. SHE WAS
TOO TRAUMATIZED. SO THAT I DID
BECAUSE I DIDN'T WANT HIM TO GO
UP YOU KNOW. ON THIS PERSON ARE
ALL HIS WHOLE LIFE. I THINK
IT'S THE ONE THAT TOOK IT
SOUNDS LIKE I WANT DIFFERENT
CANDIDATES AND- NO THAT'S
ALMOST. YOUNG MAN IN HIS MIND
SAYS TOTAL FRIEND HE'S WRITING
MUSIC. DAD SO. GREAT. DID YOU
THIS RESEARCH IS WERE AVAILABLE
TO YOU. THE RESOURCES OF
BEHAVIOR HEALTH RESOURCES AND
THERAPY WAS THAT READILY
AVAILABLE TO YOU YEAH I DID WAS
I WORKED IS LIKE A TREE AND
IMPATIENCE AT. THE CIVIC
MEDICAL. PATIENTS LIKE UNIT SO.
BUT THERE WAS NOTHING OF THE-
YOU KNOW GIVE IT WASN'T
ANYTHING ALL RIGHT BECAUSE OF
MY- ASSOCIATION WITH MY PAST
EMPLOYMENT. AT THIS THERAPIST.
THANK YOU. GREAT GREAT. YOU
KNOW YOU MENTIONED THAT YOU'VE
GROWN UP EXPERIENCE GUN
VIOLENCE IN YOUR COMMUNITY AND
YOU WORK CLOSELY WITH- EXCUSE
CAN TALK TO ME A LITTLE ABOUT
ANY EXAMPLES ARE STORIES. ONCE
HAS IMPACT. YOUR ENERGY YOUR
FAMILY MEMBERS OF THEIR MENTAL
HEALTH. I HAVE A LOT OF FRIENDS
THAT HAVE BEEN DEALT WITH ONE
OF OUR. IN MIDDLE SCHOOL I MEAN
NUMBER IS ONE ELEMENT WELL I
HAD A VERY CLOSE FRIEND. A
BECAUSE IT WAS IN. IT CLOSE
THAT'S A GOOD. HIM AND KILL THE
PERSON. FROM HIS COUSIN I MADE
HIM GET REVENGE THAT MADE HIM
WANT TO GO TO ON A RAMPAGE AND
SO WHAT I DID WAS I WAS THERE
FROM EVERY. DAY IF YOU WANT TO
TALK. TO YOU KNOW. I WOULD.
HELLO YEAH AND WHEN HE WAS LIKE
WHAT HIS ACTUAL STATE A MILDER
AND KNOW THAT HE ACTUALLY LIKE
KILL THAT IN I DIDN'T PUT
ANOTHER THAT IS NEW THAT HE
NEEDED AN I. SEAMAN HIM AND SO
WHAT I IS BEEN A MAYBE A LOT OF
TIMES. ALL MY FRIENDS HAVING A
GUN VIOLENCE BUT THAT. IN THE
CITY HE DIED TO GUN VIOLENCE
WAS SHOT. DO YOU AND HE. HE GOT
KILLED IN GANG VIOLENCE HE SHOT
BY GETTING MISTAKEN IDENTITY SO
THE TOLL ON ME I DIDN'T HAVE A
VENGEANCE. I JUST WANT. I WANT
TO GO OUT AND GET THIS IN AND
THE ONLY WAY TO DEAL WITH BEANS
IN THE- BACK. THE ONLY THING
YOU HAVE TO. JUST. HE SOON GO
OUT TO KILL IS. A WEDNESDAY
TALK ABOUT OR ANYTHING LIKE
THAT BUT THERE'S A DIFFERENCE
IS TO DEAL WITH SITUATIONS LIKE
THAT THING GOING AND PICKING UP
THE LINE TO SAVE MONEY THIS IS
LIFE IS TAKING A TOLL ON ME IN.
DIFFERENT WAYS. I WOULD KILL
ALL ALL THE- THIS TIME I CAN'T
EXPLAIN ALL OF THEM THANK YOU
AND LESS CLASS QUESTION I'M
MIKE I KNOW YOU TALKED ABOUT
THE GUN VIOLENCE PREVENTION
CENTER PROGRAM WHICH WE WERE
ABLE TO SUCCESSFULLY IN. SOME A
THREE. FIND YOUR CAN YOU TALK
ABOUT OTHER CAN DO YOU. YEAH I
COM A FEW MINUTES AGO TALKING
ABOUT ARMING PROHIBITED PEOPLE
ALSO CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE
ONLY IS THE ONLY STATE WHERE
WHERE WHERE WHERE WE REGISTER
INFORMATION. IS THAT WE KNOW
WHO'S THE GUY YOU CAN CALL.
REIGNING ORDER OR A MENTAL
HEALTH. TELL HIM IT'S CALLED A
BI IN ONE OF THE THINGS WERE TO
THIS CONFERENCE IS PROVIDING
SUFFICIENT TO ACTUALLY ALLOW TO
ABOUT THIS TOOL THAT WE HAVE.
AND I THINK THAT REALLY APPLIES
WE'RE GOOD GUN BY THE
CALIFORNIA HAS ON THE BOOKS AND
THAT'S TRUE. PLACES WHERE YOU
KNOW ABOUT. THOSE TOOLS ARE
BEING UTILIZED AS MUCH AS SEVEN
ONE OF THEM IS WE HAVE A LOT.
IS IN PLACE BUT WE NEED TO HAVE
THE RESOURCES FOR PEOPLE TO
UTILIZE THEM RIGHT SO I'M MORE
INVESTMENTS IN THE COMMUNITIES
AMBER BLUR YEAH ABSOLUTELY I
MEAN WE JUST LEARNED THAT
CALVERT CITY HAVE HAD ALREADY
BEEN IN HOW MUCH. THREE TIMES
FASTER THAN NOT ALBERT CITY SO
THAT'S- HAVING A MAJOR IMPACT
WE NEED. GREAT WELL. THE FIRST
PANEL PLEASE ANOTHER ROUND OF
APPLAUSE FOR. PANEL
. SO. THE
PANEL OF MEDICAL EXPERTS TO
TALK ABOUT THE INCIDENT AND-
LYING CAUSES OF THE ISSUES AND
I WOULD ASK FOLKS CAN TO PLEASE
SELF INTEREST. AND WILL START
RIGHT HERE. GREAT EVERYONE AND
THANK U. S. TIMELY MEMBER WAKE
AND- OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
TODAY REALLY HUMBLED TO BE
AMONG GROUP WE JUST MINUTES
AFTER THE SPEECH. ADDRESS
IMPACTS AND BILE I. MANY CALL
KRAVITZ WHERE I'M A PUBLIC
HEALTH. A CLINICIAN BUT AS THE
SALAD THE ALA JOB AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA DAVIS
VIOLENCE PER. SO HOW DO YOU SEE
FIRE VIOLENCE RESEARCH. THE
MONK AND HEALTH AN ACT. I DON'T.
BECAUSE IT IS BACK TO FLEE.
AGED FIFTEEN TO NINETEEN IN
CALIFORNIA BLACK YOUTH OF THE
SAME EIGHT SIDE IS THE LEADING
CAUSE OF. OVERALL FIREARMS ARE
INVOLVED. 30% IS HOMICIDE YOUTH
WHO IS HIS ME AN EIGHTY FIVE
PERCENT. I'D COMES TO THIS SITE
ACCESS TO RESCUE THREE TIMES
OUR RESEARCH. WE CONDUCTED THE
FIRST DAY OF FIREARM OWNERS IN
CALIFORNIA IN MORE THAN FORTY
YEARS WE FOUND THAT AN S. SEVEN
POINT THREE MILLION ADULTS LIVE
IN HOME RUNS. AND THEN YOU'RE
IN FIVE. FIREARM LOADED AND
UNLOCKED THE LEAST SECURE. FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE STRUGGLE WITH
DEPRESSION TITLE THOUGHT SYSTEM
AND SECURED GOT CAN BE. NOW.
80% OF U. S. AMONG CHILDREN AND
TEENS INVOLVED A FIREARM BELONG.
HELLO MY INTEREST MAY HAVE A
ROLE TO PLAY. OTHER STATE
SIMILAR I SUGGEST THAT WHAT
LIFE. FOR EVERY TWENTY ORDERS
TO PREVENT SUICIDE. WHEN IT
COMES TO FIGHT. THAT'S THE ONLY
THE TWO. AND EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT VISITS FIRE RATED-
VIOLENT INJURIES DEATH BY FIVE
TIMES AND SOME GROUPS BEAR DISH
TO SHARE OF THIS BIRD. THE SIX.
AND. THIRTY IS BORN IN COMPACT
ALARM CONTEXT IN AN ONGOING
LEGACY OF STRUCTURAL AND BE AN
EMIGRE SCHISM WHICH IS TO ME
ACCESS TO AND TRUST IN BASED.
SPORTS IS THAT WHEN YOUNG
PEOPLE OF COLOR ARE VICTIMS OF
VIOLENCE THEY ARE LESS LIKELY
TO SEEK AND RECEIVE SUPPORT
MORE LATE. TO LET. THIS
RESEARCH TO BE PRESSED. AMONG
THE 9% BY ONLY INJURED PATIENTS
NINE TO TWELVE AND SEVENTY PULL
FOR TEN OF THOSE AGES THIRTEEN
TO SEVENTEEN ADDITIONAL
RESEARCH BY OUR TEAM AND
SUGGEST NO HEALTH CONSEQUENCES
OF VIOLENCE IN. SECURELY SEVERE
FIREARM IS. HOSPITAL INTO
VIOLENCE INTERVENTION PROGRAMS
ALONG EFFORT SUCH AS YOUR
VIOLENCE ON FIRE DEMONSTRATED
SHINS IMPROVED HEALING FROM.
EMOTIONAL TRAUMA FOLLOWING
ISLAND. WHAT INJURED ADOLESCENT
YOUNG AND PROCEEDED BACKS BUSH
ABOVE FORMS OF VIOLENCE AND
EXPERIENCES. UNITY VIOLENCE
NATIONALLY IN ESTIMATED 13% OF
FOURTEEN TO EIGHTEEN YEAR OLDS
HAVE WITNESSED DURING LIFETIME
AND RESEARCHED IS THAT THE
COMPENSATION OF PLEASURE TO
MORE. VIOLENCE CAN HAVE A
CUMULATIVE OF. A COMPREHENSIVE
PUBLIC HEALTH APPROACH THIS
CALL FOR AN ENDING. AND
ADDRESSING THE IMPACT ISLAND
VIOLENT. YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH
INDIVIDUAL IS JUST AWESOME.
JEEZ PREVENT MY- ALLY BEFORE IT
OCCURS IN THE FIRST PLACE THANK.
HI I'M DOCTOR AMY BARN CYCLE
DAVIS AND I PATIENTS IN OUR
COUNTY PRICES IN IT PATIENT.
YOUR AMAZON GLOBAL FIREARM
SUICIDE SCHOOL SHOOTINGS HOW.
AND SOME ISSUE DOES THAT SHOW
PROMISE IN RICH. LAST YEAR
PLEASE TEN YEAR OLD AFTER
AMERICAN. DO THE PRICE IS RIGHT
BECAUSE YOU SURE TO SCHOOL THAT
HE WAS TELLING CONSIDERING
OVERDOSE. FROM THAT HE'D BEEN
REALLY DIM AND WITHDRAWN AT
HOME AND SO. UNTIL HE FELT
AFTER BACK TO HOME WITH HIS
MOM. WE LEFT HE HADN'T FELT IT
WAS SILENT OVER A WEEK AND HE
WAS REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO
GOING TO SCHOOL THING THAT
FRIENDS AND GETTING BACK TO THE
BASKETBALL TEAM. WE HE FOUND A
GUN IN A- HAD. THIRTY YEARS
WHAT CAN MAN WHO WILL CALL AND-
ZERO EIGHT TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN. AND THESE DESPERATE
MUCH GREATER MEDIA ATTENTION
THAT'S LIKE DATA. TWO THINGS
RESPONSIBLE. TEEN OKAY TWO
THREE TWELVE EPISODES THAT YEAR.
ACTIVE AS IT CAN AMERICA DO YOU.
TIMES. SUICIDE THAT WAS HIS AND.
BRAINS ARE DEVELOPING AT THAT
AGE. SIGN YOUR WITH TEENAGERS
EXPERIENCE ON A DAILY BASIS
THEIR BRAINS MAKES THEM
VULNERABLE TO ATTEND. RISK
TAKING SELF CONTROL ADVANCE
PLANNING AND- SHIN LAG FAR
BEHIND THIS MEANS A TEENAGER
LIKE JADEN ARE MUCH MORE
NEUROLOGICALLY PREDISPOSED FOR
EXAMPLE ATTEMPT SUICIDE AT
BREAK UP OR A BAD DAY FIRST
VIOLENT FANTASIES ABOUT
CONSIDERING THE LONG TERM KERR.
OR THE HOPES THAT MAKE A BETTER
FUTURE. AND THERE TWO DON'T
ATTEMPT TIGHTER PERPETRATE
VIOLENT. WOULD IT MEAN EIGHTIES
BUT THEIR HOMES OR THEIR
SCHOOLS OR VOLUME TURNS LOGIC
ONCE A. TEENAGERS WITHOUT SET.
I LET IT SUFFER THE MOST
DECORATED GREAT CARE IN THE
HOSPITAL WE WENT HOME TO A BUSY
SINGLE. STOP SCHOOL WITH NO
HEALTH RESOURCES A FOLLOW UP
APPOINTMENT AND OVERWHELMED
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM. AND A
NEIGHBORHOOD BURGER VIOLENT
CRIME WERE COMMON AND WHERE
MANY. DOT SAFETY WE KNOW THE
ALL THESE THINGS CONTRIBUTE.
BUT DOES LIKE JAY. ALSO PREVENT
PROMINENT PEERS AND FAMILY AND-
FROM LOSING HIM MENTAL HEALTH
AND VIOLENCE PREVENTION
RESOURCES IN SCHOOLS CAN
INTERVENE WITH THOSE AT RISK
AND THEY CAN ALSO BREAK THE
CYCLE OF VIOLENCE AND SUICIDE.
TRY TO DISCUSS. WE JUST ON THE
TOP GOOD INTENTIONS TRAINED
PROFESSIONALS IN THE SCHOOL TWO
SIDED TEMPS BY AT. GIVENS
KIRSTEN. YOUR DIET AND
PROFESSIONAL CAN LEAD TO LOWER
LEVELS OF PTSD DEPRESSION
FUTURE PROBLEMS IN STUDENTS
THAT RECEIPT. THOSE WHO DON'T.
HAVING THIS PROGRAM THE SCHOOL
SYSTEM AND HAVING THEM FIVE.
MAKES IT EASIER FOR ALL
FAMILIES WORKING WITH MANY IT'S
EASY TO ACCESS THESE. AND
PERHAPS DIFFICULT BUT THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING WE CAN DO TO
REDUCE IT DOWN BY DON ARE YOU.
REDUCING THE DISPARITY SOCIAL
TERMINATE OFF THE- AND LACK OF
ACCESS TO. GOOD EDUCATION THE
JADE AND SO MANY OF OUR OTHER
CHILDREN HERE IN COUGH. GOOD
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU SO MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WAY CAN BE. I'M
ROCHELLE DECKER I'M A TRY.
PRACTICED AT NUMBERS IS GOOD.
FOR ABOUT EIGHTEEN YEARS AND
I'M- WHEN I WAS IN SAN
FRANCISCO SO I STARTED THE
WRAPAROUND PROJECT A HOSPITAL
BASED INTERVENTION GRAHAM. I
FOUND MY SISTERS AND. CRAP OUR
SHIP FIVE. VIOLENCE PENSION AND
THAT'S BEEN GOING FOR TEN YEARS
SO I REMEMBER VERY VIVIDLY
TAKING CARE OF AN ELEVEN YEAR
OLD BOY HAD BEEN SHOT THE NEXT
NIGHT AND AFTER HIS OPERATION
MORNING WE WHEN I'M ROUNDS TO
SEE HIM AND HE HAD. PULLED ALL
THE WAY UP AND AS WE ENTERED
THE ROOM. TO TALK TO A- IN AN
EXAM I. AND HAVING IT AND.
PEOPLE LEAVING THE ROOM SAYING
THE CALL AND I SAT WITH HIM FOR
A LITTLE WHILE AND TRIED TO
COAX THE SEATS ONE. THE. THE
POCKET HELLO SO THAT'S I CALLED
MY- POSSIBLE THESE FACTS
INTERVENTION CASE WHAT ARE AND
HE HELPED ME TO PEEL THE LAYERS
AND WITHOUT THAT MENTAL HEALTH
PORT THERE'S NO WAY THAT WE
COULD HAVE IT COMPREHENSIVE
SUPPORT. AND HEALING FOR THE
YOUNG INDIVIDUAL. HE DID TOTAL
MENTAL AND SO DOES THE TRAUMA
CENTERS SO TO OUR SCHOOLS TO
REALLY HEAL PEOPLE AND BEGIN TO
LET PEOPLE SEE IF NOT JUST TO
SAVE OUR LIVES BUT- THEM TO
START LOOK. CHILDREN OF YES THE
ANXIETY TO. A LOT OF A GROUP
BEHAVE AS WE'VE BEEN HEARING
ALL AFTERNOON THEY CAN'T SLEEP
AT NIGHT THE SCHOOL TO SLEEP
AND THEN THEN THEY'RE NOT HEARD
AND SO YOU'RE AGGRESSIVE AND
THEY TO GO TO THE POOL FOR THAT
REASON TOO SO THEY. AND A
TRAUMA INFORMED APPROACH SO
THAT WE DON'T ALL PEOPLE DO IS.
PROVIDE FOR ALL OUR INSTITUTION.
RHYS POPULATIONS CLEARLY A MAP
OUT IN OUR CITIES AND THERE ARE
TOWNS IN IN. AND IF WE BUT
THOSE ARE THE SAME CITIES AND
AREAS THANK YOU LITERALLY WHERE
WE SEE POVERTY. WHERE WE SEE
FOOD DESERT OTHER CHRONIC
DISEASES NOT GUN VIOLENCE YOU
CAN DO SOMETHING ABOUT THIS
EXAMPLE CREATE POLICIES CHOIR
I'M IN THE PRO JEW INTERN. ****
AT SO THAT WE DON'T. PATIENT
WHOSE DIFFICULT BUT WE HAVE
SYMPATHY AND WE DON'T
TRAUMATIZE ARE YOU. INVESTING
IN WHOLE PERSON CARE AND- SLING
HOSPITAL BASED ON LINK VIOLENCE
INTERVENTION PROGRAM. SOMETHING
WE'RE STARTING TO DO SOME CAN
DO. AND IT'S DEMONSTRATING
GREAT RESULTS AND THEN OF
COURSE AS HAS ALREADY MENTIONED
HEREIN STING AND ARC IS IN
PROVIDING OPPORTUNITIES SO THAT
SO THAT UNITY. LIFT UP IF YOU
HAVE WEALTH YOU HAVE HEALTH AND
SO THE STATE CAN INCENTIVE IS
TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE. IN A
MINUTE. DOUBT MY CASE THERE'S
NO. AT ELEVEN YEAR OLD THRIVE
COULD'VE WALKED BY AND THE
LAYERS OF THOSE SHEETS ON- BUT-
UNACCEPTABLE. HERE IN
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. INTERVENTION
PROMISE. IN MY. A CONSTANT I'M
A PEDIATRICIAN WITH HAS A
PERMIT SAN FRANCISCO ALSO WITH
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL SYSTEM
AND WE'RE A- ERIN VIOLENT SHIN.
A COUPLE YEARS AGO AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE. YOU
KNOW REDUCING VIOLENCE ISN'T.
THE NEED AND THE IMPACT OF THE
VAN. UP TOWARDS BOTH PREVENTION
AND RECOVERY THAT WE'VE HEARD
TODAY WELL CALIFORNIA'S TAKEN
SIGNIFICANCE TO REDUCE THE
AVAILABILITY OF GUNS WITH ALL
OF THE REGULATIONS POLICIES WE
HAVE THERE'S NO MORE TO DO.
YOUR CHILDREN AS YOU HEARD OUR
DAY DISPROPORTIONATELY BY THAT
WE HEARD TODAY THAT. YOUTH ZERO
EIGHTEEN IT'S THE THIRD- REST
FACTOR. OR DEATH THIS IS JUST A
SOBERING. THIRTY VIOLENCE BASED
ON THEIR PART WAYS ALL. AS MY
FARM VIOLENCE HAS TO WHAT
IMPACT ON NOT JUST. BUT ALSO
FAMILY AND THE GROUP. AS WELL
AS THE ORGANIZATION COMMUNITY
THAT THERE ARE THAT THEY ARE
INVOLVED. AND I'VE REALLY SEEN
THIS FIRSTHAND IN MY PRACTICE-
THE FAMILY HAVE BEEN IN CARE OF
FOR FIFTEEN YEARS AND THREE OUT
OF THIS WOMAN THIS MOTHER.
FIXTURE BEEN HIRED. FRIENDS AND
FIVE. THE THREE TO FOUR FIRST
AND- I KNOW ABOUT IT I'VE DONE
A THING POSSIBLE FOR THIS
FAMILY TO PROVIDE HEALTH CARE
FOR THEM AND YOU. BREAK THAT.
WITH JUST ME IN OFFICE TOP WITH.
SO IT'S REALLY- THAT'S UP TO ME
IN TERMS OF WHAT'S THE ROLE OF
OUR MEDICAL. THIS WORK AND MY
ROLE IS. ASSESSING FOR RISK OF
MATH AND WRITING THE PLANE AND
TOP OUT SAFE STORAGE OF GUNS
IT'S TALKING A- REDUCTION WHEN
I HAVE. SOMEONE WITH MANTA
LESSON TALKING ABOUT SAFETY
GONE ARE GETTING A GUN OUT OF
THE HOMES THAT SUICIDE DOESN'T
HAPPEN. THEN IT'S EXHAUSTING AS
RSS FOR EXPORT. BUT THEN THE
NEXT PIECE IS THE COMMUNITY
PIECE AND THE PARTNERSHIP THAT
I CAN HAVE WITH THAT WITH THE
BIGGER MEDICAL COMMUNITY WITH
ALL OF THE COMMUNITY BASED
PROGRAMS. AND WE'VE HEARD TODAY
ABOUT THE FULL OF POVERTY AND
THE BOMB WE'VE HEARD ABOUT.
ISSUE AROUND. TO RAISE THEM AND
WE'VE HEARD ABOUT SHOES AND A
CHIN AND SOME OF THE LACK OF
OPPORTUNITY. BLOOD THINNER
CATION ALL SYSTEM AND SO I'D
LOVE TO. PUBLIC HEALTH. MY PART
THE MEDICAL COMMUNITY AND
PARTNER WITH COMMUNITY HEALTH
AND THE COMMUNITY BASED
PROGRAMS SPACE AND I REALLY DO
THINK MORE IN THE POLLS WHERE
ARE. SPEND SO MANY THERE IS A
REAL CHANCE. A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITY THAT AT SOME SKILL
IS TO HELP CHILDREN UNDERSTAND
SHINS AND. THESE PROGRAMS ABOUT
HOW TO HANDLE SOME OF THESE
EMOTIONS AND THEN THE
RECOGNITION WHEN THE REMOTE TOO
MUCH AND THAT THEY NEED A
HIGHER LEVEL MENTAL HEALTH CARE.
MY NAME IS KHAN SHOT LIVE HERE.
AND DOCTOR AND RESEARCHER AT
UCSF BENIOFF CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL OAKLAND. HAVE A
TEENAGER WE CARE AND THE- VINYL
ENGINE. A YOUNG ADULT THE GUN
VIOLENCE RECENTLY COMPLETED THE
TO EXAMINE CHILDREN WHO ARE
DIRECTLY EXPOSED TO. LANCE
INCLUDING GONE BY. WARM UP. ALL
RIGHT PRESS FOR DYING AFTER
SURVIVOR SHOW INJURY. WE IT IS
THE- BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWO THOUSAND NINE AT THE THREE
TRAUMA CENTERS IN ALAMEDA AND
SAN FRANCISCO COUNTIES. AT THE
RISK OF DEATH FOR TWELVE
EIGHTEEN AMONG RESEARCH. ALL MY
FIVE R. ARM. AND ON. ALL LONG
TERM DEATHS WERE BY HONDA I'D
WHICH CAUSED THE DEATHS IN ALL
THREE GROUPS. INDIVIDUALS. ONE
TO SIX YEARS AFTER THE INITIAL
INJURIES AT AN AVERAGE AGE
NINETEEN OR TWENTY. AFTER
ACCOUNTING FOR OTHER FACTORS WE
FOUND THAT ADOLESCENT AGE SALES
TAX BLACK GREAT AND PUBLICAN
STATUS IN THE REST. FOR LONG
TERM MORTALITY. THESE ARE ALSO
DESCRIBED AS A DAY MENTIONED IN
THE LITERATURE AS ACTORS. BY
LIKE WHAT REGARDLESS I FIVE
OTHER ME IS IN. THE RISK OF
LONG. TO UNINTENTIONAL NON BY.
THESE FINDINGS AGAIN WHAT IS
THAT BLACK MALE IN THE SOCIO
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED.
TALLY ALSO SHOW IT ON THE FACT
THAT CHILDREN WHO OUT OF THE
VEHICLE SYSTEM DOING DUE TO ANY.
HI FOR EXAMPLE. BLACK T. AGE
BOYS WHO SURVIVED. WHAT AS A
CHRISTIAN I'M AN ADDICT. SH TWO
GUNBOATS PREVENT. BEING A
SALTER ASSAULTED IS A MARKER OF
RISK LIKELY RELATED TO
NEIGHBORHOOD SOCIAL X. FROM
ATOP FROM WHICH THE CHILD
ARRIVES TO MERIT ATTENTION AND
TO WHICH THEY RETURN CAN ALSO
HAVE DIRECT DOWN PAYMENT.
INCLUDE MORE PROTECTIVE. SITE
INTERVENTIONS TARGETING
CHILDREN ASSAULT HOW TO PROTECT.
SAME TOOLS ON VICTIM TO BEING
INVOLVED WITH GOT ONCE. YOUR
SHIP EIGHTY SIX NO THREE WAS AN
IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD IN
CONTINUING TO IT IS BASED. IT'S
LIKE CLEANSE PROCESS. WOULD BE
TWO X. RESOURCES TO HIGH RISK
ADOLESCENTS WHO EXPERIENCE
OTHER FORMS OF VIOLENCE AS WELL
AS THOSE DISCHARGED FROM THE-
CALIFORNIA CAN YOU TAKE THE
LEAD IN FRONT. IN RESEARCH YOU
GOT IT IF. IS THAT IT BOTH
SOCIAL AND ENVIRONMENTAL
MINUTES OF VIOLENCE. I URGE YOU
TO WORK TOWARDS FILLING THE GAP
IN PEDIATRIC MENTAL HEALTH
RESOURCES PARTICULAR SET IT.
PILOT TRAUMA CHILDREN WITH.
EMERGENCIES WHICH ARE IS DUE TO
THE DEARTH OF PATIENTS
PSYCHIATRIC BEDS JUST WAIT TO
ACCESS OUTPATIENT MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND IN ONE COUNTY OF
ALAMEDA THERE IS NO MATTER. FOR
H. JUNE THE U. S. SOME MEMBERS.
AND I WANT TO THINK THESE
AMAZING COLLEAGUES WHO HAVEN'T
TO THEIR CAREERS TO SUPPORT
CHILDREN AND YOUTH IT. IN THE
MALL- HERE TODAY THAT SHARED
STORIES AS YOU GUYS ARE
INSPIRATION FOR ALL OF OUR WORK
THAT WE DO. THERE ARE REALLY
THREE THINGS THAT I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT TODAY AND THIS. IS
AN UNDERSTANDING OF THE
EVIDENCE IS BETWEEN. TRUMP.
SPITTLE AND- ABOUT. MENTAL
HEALTH GOING OR WHERE I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF OUR CENTER FOR
CHILD AND COMMUNITY HEALTH AT
USING ANY OFF CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL OAKLAND ALSO A CO LEAD
FREEZE SURE IN OUR ADVERSE
BECAUSE. STUDY WITH MY
COLLEAGUES AT UCSF AND WITH OUR
CHURCH IN GENERAL. THERE WAS A
MAN IN THE- THESE IT WAS THE
INITIAL. TODD LOOKS AND SAYS
THAT WAS DONE AT KAISER. K. AND
THE CENTER FOR DISEASE CAN. AND
WHAT THIS STUDY WHAT STUDY THAT
MADE THE CORRELATION WITH
DRAMATIC EXPERIENCES AND HEALTH
THIS IS ALSO WE THINK OF.
PHYSICAL HEALTH FROM. LEARN
WHEN WE INITIALLY ISSUES OF
ABUSE NEGLECT AND HOUSEHOLD
THIS FUNCTION BUT ARE THE
DEFINITIONS OF ADVERSE. WE
FOUND IS THAT THIS CHILD
EXPERIENCES OR OR MORE OF THESE
AT. THREE THERE ARE THREE TIMES
MORE LIKELY TO HAVE PHYSICAL.
THERE I PLEAD THE- LIKELY TO
ENGAGE IN SUBSTANCE USE AN
ATTEMPT SUICIDE. THREE TWO
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO HAVE
LEARNING A BEHAVIORAL ISSUES
THEY'VE EXPERIENCED NEVER
TRAUMA FOR THEIR FOR THEIR
THIRTEEN YEARS OF LIFE. WE
BRING THIS DOWN NOT A LEVEL TO
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN CALIFORNIA
WE. 64% OF CALIFORNIANS PRINCE
PLEASE WHAT TRUMP. I HAVE
EXPERIENCE FOR MORE. THREE TRY
UNDERNEATH OUR STAND MIXER
BRAIN I PICTURE IT AFFECTS OUR
DNA IT OWNS AN ARM YOU KNOW
THAT OUR IMMUNE SYSTEMS THE
WORK THAT WE'RE DOING EASIEST
ANY OPTIONAL. IT TOOK SCREEN.
KIDS ACES AND TRAUMA THAT CLUES
EXPOSURE TO VIOLENT. THE
NEIGHBORHOOD HOMES AS WELL AS-
WITH. WITH THE KIDS. THE
COMPANY WE KNOW OVER 80% OF
THEM HAVE XP INSIGNIFICANT
TRAUMA AND A HALF. OR MORE
THESE ARE VERY YOUNG AVERAGE
AGES FIVE AND UP KIDS THAT HAVE
EXPERIENCE FOR MORE DIFFERENT
TYPES. THE REDUCTION IN THEIR
CALL FUNCTION. NEVER CAN
IMPAIRMENT BEFORE THEY EVEN GET
TO KINDERGARTEN. WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT SCHOOL RIGHT. WE HAVE TO
REALIZE THAT PERHAPS A VIRTUAL
HAVE IN COMMON TEN BEFORE YOU
CAN STOP INTO THE DOORS OF THE
CLASSROOM. TO THE THAT THEY'VE
EXPIRY. WE'VE BEEN WORKING HELP
PART SERVICE. ACTUALLY PASSED
LEGISLATION MANDATES UNIT. FOR
EVERY SINGLE CHILD IN. SEVEN
MILLION CHILDREN USING THE
TOOLS WE CREATE ANY OF SPITTLE
CALLED. ROLLING UP PERSONAL
READING FOR. IT HAPPENS NEXT
YOU FOR YOUR MANY. THIRTY SO I
REALLY- JUST ALL NOT PLEASE
SUPPORT IN THE FIRST INNING BUT
TO THINK ABOUT HOW WE'RE
REIMBURSING HEALTH SERVICES-
OUR SUPPORTING COMMUNITY BASED
IN IRVINE AND- DOES FOOD BANKS.
PREVENTION PROGRAMS THAT YOU'RE
THAT YOU HEARD ABOUT HERE TODAY.
REALLY IMPORTANT WE CAN RAISE
AN S. INCLUDING LAW ENFORCEMENT
SCHOOLS AND HEALTH CARE AN
AWARENESS OF NOT WHAT'S WRONG.
WHAT'S HAPPENING TO OUR
CHILDREN SEX VIOLENCE THAT
THEY'RE EXPERIENCING SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. A DOCTOR LONG
QUESTION FOR YOU ON THE P. I'M.
PROVIDES SO ONCE HELD SCREEN
FOR THIS. THAT INFORMATION AND
HOW DO YOU PRESS THE SITUATION
THANK YOU SIR THE QUESTION
WE'VE BEEN WORKING REALLY
CLOSELY WITH HEALTH SERVICES IN
ORDER TO CREATE ALGORITHMS FOR
HOW DO YOU SEE IN WHAT DO YOU
DO WHAT. I KNOW IS THAT. ACES
ARE ADVERSE EXPERIENCES HAVE A
DOES. IT REALLY INSURE POOR
HEALTH AND SO IT CHILD CAN
EIGHT ONE THREE AND WE- AND
SOME POLICY WHETHER EARNING A-
AS MAYA AND WHAT WE'RE FINDING
IS THAT IF KIDS BRING POSITIVE
THE FIRST STEP IS THAT WE- DO
YOUR TRIP. PRIMARY CARE. NEED
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A HEART
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE FAMILY
BE ABLE TO ACCESS. SOME TRAUMA
FACTOR BE CARE RATE SO MUCH FUN
WHAT MEDICINE IS ABOUT TRUSTING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THEIR
FAMILIES WE ALSO NEED TO BE
ABLE TO DEVELOP MY. WE CAN FOR
FAMILIES TO COMMUTE BASEMENT
OKAY. SERVICES THROUGH MEDICAID
TYPE. AND SOME FROM DOWN A
MENTAL HEALTH ALL THE STATE AND
ALTHOUGH IT'S REALLY. OFF IT'S
LIKE NOT- DISTRUSTFUL AND SO IF
WE CAN ACTUALLY TO SUPPORT-
DRINKS AND GET MORE HOUSING FOR
FOLKS THEY'LL BE LESS THAT'S
WHAT'S CALLED WEST. ULTIMATE
REDUCING EXPOSURE IS OFTEN ONE
GENERATION. AND HELLO AND
DOCTOR DECKER. THE EXAMPLE THAT
YOU GAVE IF THE GENERAL NEEDED
TOTAL MENTAL HELP. WHAT WOULD
PLAY IN AN IDEAL WORLD. IN
TOTAL HENCE OF MY. WOULD MEAN
THAT JUST LIKE IT'S ESSENTIAL
TO HAVE A TRAUMA. HE MET HIS
CHIN FIRST A MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDE. INTO A CENTER IS
EMBEDDED IN TRAUMA CENTERS AND
ELBOW IN A CULTURALLY
APPROPRIATE. THAT WOULD BE PART
OF THE ROOF SETTING UP AND THAT.
SO FOR THAT INITIAL ESPECIALLY.
THEN WHAT ABOUT THE LONGER TERM
PEACE AS WELL YEAH AS WE- WHICH
I DON'T IN MY PROFESSION. IN
THEIR BILLS THE- WE WERE- THERE
CAN BE CURRICULUM DEVELOPMENT
AND FOR WHICH IS GREAT BECAUSE
PROVIDES. OPPORTUNITIES FOR
EMPLOYMENT THOSE WHO REALLY GET
IT. UNDERSTANDING AND CAN
REALLY CONTRIBUTE FOR THE NEXT
GENERATION GREAT WHEN I THINK
OF OUR SECOND PANEL HERE FOR
CUSTOM AND WE'LL INVITE OUR
THIRD PANEL
. SO THIS PANEL. A
GROUP OF LOCAL AT A KIDS
WORKING ON SOUND AND ENERGIES
TO DENNIS LUCIEN'S THESE ISSUES
I WANT TO WELCOME OUR- PLEASE
INTRODUCE. YEAH THE CHILDREN.
IT IS OFTEN USED WHEN YOU
TESTIFY. THANK YOU IT'S IN
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO BRING.
POWERFUL COMPREHENSIVE
CONVERSATIONS I AM REALLY
EXCITED. I WANT TO START BY
SAYING YOU KNOW. THE RIGHT TO
LIVE LEARN GROW AND GROW UP
FEELING SAFE AND MY FEAR. AND
LIGHT EVERYTHING THAT YOU'VE
ALREADY FELLOW PANEL I WOULD
LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT THE RACIAL
JUST. THE SOLUTIONS THE ACCESS
TO HEALTHY FOR YOU. THE POOR
CHILDREN AND YOU'VE HEARD IN
CHILDREN OF COLOR ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY. COMMA TALKS
IT DRESS ACES AND THEY'RE MORE
LIKELY TO ENCOUNTER AT LEAST
ONE SHOT THEN IN THE WHAT. 60%
CHILDREN PERCENT OF LATINO. MY
EXPERIENCE AT LEAST AT THE
VENICE YOU JUST HEARD FROM
DOCTOR A LOT ABOUT THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THAT ALL 40% OF
THEIR WHITE. PEERS HAVE ONLY
HEARING IT'S TWO ONE. TO
OPERATE AS A MICRO LEVEL MESS
LEVEL AND- A LEVEL NOMINA THAT
EXTENDS FAR BEYOND THE
IMMEDIATE VICTIMS. WITHOUT ALSO
UNDERSTANDING. AT THE
RACIALIZED WITH RISK LEVELING
THE GUN VIOLENCE DEBATE IN
CREATING POLICY THERE NEITHER
POLITICALLY MEANING OR
PRACTICALLY EFFECTIVE
PRACTICALLY EFFECTIVE TOWARD
THE BROUGHT THE COMPLEX ISSUE
OF GUN VIOLENCE AND ITS EFFECT
ON YOUTH AND MENTAL HEALTH OUR
HEALTH SAFETY NET AS FEELING
CURRENT. IN ADDRESSING THE MISS
TEXAS. MORE THAN HALF OF ALL
UNDER THE AGE OF TWENTY ONE.
SURE MEDIC COW. TITLE TO ALL
THE MEDICALLY NECESSARY ON
MENTAL HEALTH THE HEALTH OF
SERVICE UNDER FEDERAL LAW.
AUDIT FOUND THAT A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY. HUNDRED THOUSAND
CHILDREN DIED SEVERE. EMOTIONAL
DISORDER RECEIVE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES SCREENING CHILDREN
FROM HIGH. HAVING A SYSTEM TO
TREAT THEM ON EXCEPT. AT BEST
AT THE CORE OF. POLICY MAKERS.
ROLE TO PLAY THERE ARE TWO
HOUSES DO NOT CONTAIN FELL
CHILDREN ARE MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. FOCUS OUR
ATTENTION. IN A RELIABLE TRAUMA
INFORMED MENTAL HEALTH CARE TO
THE SYSTEM. EASILY ACCESS AND
LOCAL SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITIES
INTERVENTION IN PROGRAMS LIKE
RISELEY. WHEN THESE ELEMENTS
THERE IS A LITTLE TOO GREAT A
SERVICES THAT ARE SUPPOSE I
SHOULD TRUST A COMMUNITY LEADER.
WE CAN FOR SUPPORT MORE
PROGRAMS LIKE THIS IN OTHERS
LOS. DITION WE CAN BRING BACK
LEVEL. THE BASE FOR THE NIGHT
START. IN LISTED TRUST
COMMUNITY COORDINATORS IN
SCHOOL TO HELP THE HELP. FAMILY
THRIVE I WANT ESPECIALLY
LEADERSHIP WHICH I'M SURE WILL
BREAKS ON CHAMPIONING AB EIGHT
FIVE AND BY RESOURCING HEALTHY
START PROGRAMS WE KNOW THAT OR
IS HE IN COMMUNITIES CAN
ADDRESS THE EFFECTS OF ALL THE
TRAUMA BY BUILDING. SAFE SAFE
HAVING COMMUNITIES FOR CHILDREN
WITH THANK YOU. RIGHT KING.
THREE THANK ALSO- THE BLOOD CAN
I GET TO BE A PART OF ALSO ONE
I THINK THE YOUNG PEOPLE OF
COLOR WHO ORGANIZE FOR THE
RISE. IN TWO DECADES AGO. STAND
AFTER I SPOKE Q. MISSIONS OF
VIOLENCE AND SEXUAL CONDITIONS
OF VIOLENCE YOU CAN'T DO WANTED
THERE AND SO I STAND ON THE
SHOULDERS OF THEM ARE NOT WITH.
DAY SO I'M HERE IN OUR- THE
RAGE AND ANGER THE PAIN YOU FOR
ME IS IT. IT'S HONORING THE MEN
OF THEIR WORK AND THEIR REST IN
THEIR BRAVE. SO TWO THINGS I
WANT TO TALK ABOUT WE ARE NOT
MUSICIAN TO PROVIDE DIRECT
SPORTSWEAR FIRST- TO THIS TO
LEGALIZE THE GUN AND- SUBMIT
WORK AROUND PLEASE IT. DOES IS
IT A LITTLE THE STRUCTURAL
CONDITIONS. AS ASIAN OUR
COMMUNITIES FACE WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT GUN VIOLENCE TALK ABOUT
GUN VIOLENCE AS A- STATE. THE
STATE MY LISINOPRIL LOOKING
DOWN MY PANTS WE ACTUALLY HAVE
TO INTERVENE THE STATE AND THE
SYSTEMS IN THE RELATIONSHIP IN
THE SYSTEMS. THE CONDITIONS IN
OUR NEIGHBORHOOD IN OUR
COMMUNITY SO THIS MEANS MORE
COMPLICATED WE GOT TO BE MORE
MESSY. WE ACTUALLY UP TO ONE OF
OUR- SOME UP TO ACTUALLY MOVE
BY THE POSITION. AND BUILD UP.
THOSE MOST PROXIMATE AND WE SAW
SOME FOLKS ON THE PANEL TODAY
THE OTHER THING I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT IS WE PROVIDE THE HOUSE
RACES WE PROVIDE CLINICAL
SERVER IS THAT RIGHT. CBT IS
BASED OFF. SAY IT WE DIDN'T
PROVIDE IT WITHIN A MILIEU OF
BEING HERE HONOR OF BEING JUST
A STANDARD OF THE- WORRY THAT
DOES PROPER SAYS WOULD DO MORE
HARM TO OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
BECAUSE ONLY. ABOUT MENTAL
HEALTH WE STILL TALK ABOUT AS
INDIVIDUAL. WHAT IS ACTUALLY.
HERE THIS ATMOSPHERE. TRAPS AND
THAT DISTRESSES WHAT THIS
COUNTRY IS BUILT UP WHAT THE
COMMUNITIES THAT. NAVIGATING
EVERY DAY SO WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. IT'S IN BAD SIDE OF THE
HOUSE. IS THAT NOT FIRST
EXPERIENCE OF VIOLENCE OR
TRAUMA AND THEY MIGHT. ACES AND
IT DOESN'T NAVIGATING
STRUCTURAL SCHISM I KNOW WE
TALKED. WE NAME IT BUT HER CHIN.
INDIVIDUAL BEHAVIOR AND WE
STILL FOLLOW JUST BLACK AND
BROWN PEOPLE AND SO WHAT I
WOULD PROPOSE AND WE HOPE WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS
INTERVENTION WAS THE RESEARCH
THE POLICY ALL HAS TO COME WORK
EXTRA HARD. THOSE OF YOU DOING.
I IMPLORE YOU TO STOP USING
CONVENTIONAL SPECIAL STANDS
FOR- RESEARCH MARKS YOU NEED TO
LOOK AT SOME X. YOU NEED TO
LOOK AT THE LITERATURE. HE JUST
LOOKING UP AT ABOUT THIRTY
MINUTES TO REFLECT THE ALIVE
PEOPLE AND RIGHT NOW EVEN WITH
A CALIBER. THAT WE GET OUTCOMES
DO NOT REFLECT LIVED XP
PRIORITIES IN THE POWER OF OUR
COMMUNITY THEY'RE JUST OUT OF
COMPLIANCE TO WHITE SUPREMACY.
SO YEAH WE CAN MEET DOES
ANYBODY COMES ONLY NOW WE'RE
BACK. IN AND SO AGAIN. THE
STATE VIOLENCE GUN VIOLENCE IS
AN EXPRESSION AN EMBODIMENT.
MENTAL HEALTH THE ATMOSPHERE
DISTRESS SO IT'S NOT YOUR IT'S
NOT INDIVIDUAL HAS TO BE ACTIVE
SO WE HAVE TO WORK THANKS
THANKS. THE BODY AND MY NAME IS
NIKKI MCCALLUM AND I'M
ACCOUNTING SERVICES DIRECTOR
FOR YOUTH IN OAKLAND. I THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY- BEFORE TALKING. TO
FIX THE WORK OF YOU FOR LIFE
AS- MUCH ABOUT THE CURRENT
DOWNSTREAM FOR LONG TERM
SUSTAINABLE CHANGE TRACKER
THERE'S MUCH WORK TO BE DONE
UP. THE DRESSING THE ISSUE TO
TRAUMAS PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SOCIAL JUSTICE IT IS ONE OF.
THE STAINS COMING REQUIRES IS
ACCEPTABLE TO TRULY RESPONSIBLE
APPEAL ENVIRONMENT AND THAT
REQUIRES CHANGE AT THE HIGHEST
LEVELS OF INSTITUTIONAL POWER.
CHANGE YOUTH ARE NOT BAD CRAZY.
AND IN NEED OF HEALING. SYSTEMS
AN INSTITUTION A TOKEN TRUMP
INFORMED CARE CENTER. THERE IS
NEED TO FIRST TURN THAT LANDS
AT AMERICAN HOLD THEMSELVES
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR ACTIONS
IN THE WAY IN WHICH THOSE
ACTUALLY CONTRIBUTE TO THE ON
GOING FOR TRAUMA PATIENTS OF.
THESE COLOR. THE POST NOT
EXPRESSED AS PTSD TRAUMA YOU
CHANGE A PLEA PTSD MICHAEL
NOTICES AND MANY PEOPLE. TRY TO
MEET THE DIAGNOSTIC. FEE BUT
THAT DOESN'T. MY BABY IS ANY
LESS FOR. IT DOES NOT I IN
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE CONSTANTLY
BEING RE TRAUMATIZED PTSD TO
TAKE OUT THE HUMILIATION OF
STRESS ON BY POVERTY RACE RACE
THIS IS SOME DISCRIMINATION AND
VICTIMIZING THE HANDS OF THOSE
WHO OPPOSE THE POSITIONS TO
HELP. TYPICALLY POLICE SCHOOL
SERVICES. I WAS WITH A. D.
OPPOSITIONAL THAT ANOTHER
DISORDERS RESULTING IN MYSTERY
MYSTERY. AND ITS CONSEQUENCES
OFTEN INTERNALIZE THEIR OWN
STRESS AND BALANCE IS
INEVITABLE OR IS. LEFT
UNADDRESSED THIS IS HIGHLY
LIKELY TO RESULT IN FURTHER
VIOLENCE HEARD PEOPLE HURT
PEOPLE 40% OF PEOPLE GET SHOT
FOR SHOT AGAIN WITHIN TWO YEARS.
I'M FEELING. SPONSORED SERVICE
DELIVERY SERVED BY YOU FIVE
SCORE PRIOR PROGRAM THE
DISSENTERS AGAIN. BELIEVE THAT
HEALING IS POSSIBLE WE BELIEVE
THAT HEALING PREVENTS VIOLENCE
AND SAVES LIVES WE LEAD ROLE TO
PLAY IN ADDRESSING BOXES OF.
HEALTH AND JUSTICE ISSUE. LET.
NINETEEN NINETY ONE TO PREVENT
VIOLENCE AND CREATE LATE
FOCUSING ON PREVENTION
INTERVENTION HEALING UP FRONT
LINES INCLUDES INDIVIDUALS WHO
GREW UP IN THE COMMUNITY THEY
SERVE WE'VE GOT A REAL LIFE
EXPERIENCE AS MUCH AS DEGREES
AND CERTIFICATES. AFTER SIX
FROM AN BALANCES IS PUBLIC AND
SOCIAL JUSTICE PROMINENT
SCENTED ENGAGEMENT. WALLACE
BONUS WE HAVE. ALL INFORMATION
ABOUT FINDING SYMPTOMS OF
TRAUMA TO HELP PEOPLE THEY ARE
NOT CRAZY SCORE BACK FOR MANY
LEARNING ABOUT TRAUMA CENTER
HELPS THEM TO RECOGNIZE THEIR
EXPERIENCING THE NORMAL RATE
THIS IS WHAT SHOULD BE WHAT TO
WATCH WHAT IS A VERY. NORMAL
EXPERIENCE. DEALS WITH VIOLENCE
AND. POURTANT THAT WE NEVER
ACCEPT AS NORMAL AND ACCEPTABLE
WE WORK COLLABORATIVELY WITH
OUR CLIENTS AND THE WHOLE
SYSTEM IS ALWAYS RIGHT THEY ARE
THE EXPERTS ON THEIR OWN
EXPERIENCE AND WE SERVE THAT
FEEL COMFORTABLE WHEN LOOK. THE
**** IN BEIJING. IS TO CONSIDER
METRIC MEASURE TRAUMA. HE WAS
JUST A TEST NOW WHAT IS THE
RESULTS ARE INHERENTLY TEST THE
SAME IS TRUE OF ESTIMATE EVERY.
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICE THAT IT
AT THAT HAS WORKED AND WHAT.
WILL WORK IN A- CULTURALLY
RESPONSIVE INTERACTIONS
EVIDENCE AS A RESULT OF THIS
DURATION IS ESSENTIAL IT.
TRAUMA INTERVENTION. SO WHAT
CAN WE DO BEST INFORMED
HEALINGS EDUCATION AND SUPPORT
THEIR NINETIES TRAUMA BONUSES
PUBLIC. USE FOR GUARDING.
WITHIN THE EXPERTS ON THEIR. I
INPUT IN ALL STAGES OF
DEVELOPMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION.
RECOGNIZE THAT EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICE ARE AWFULLY HELPFUL IF
THEY CAN PROVE HELP THE
COMMUNITY WE ARE SERVING. BASED
EVIDENCE THAT COMES FROM. SORRY
THAT COMES IN FROM THE KEY AND
THAT MEANS PEOPLE WILL ACT AS A
CENTRAL COMPONENT ON THE PATH
TO. ONE OF THE MOST. IS NOT A
DIAGNOSIS OF PTSD AND THAT
RECOGNIZES AND RESPECTS BROADER
RANGE OF XP. SUPPORT SERVICES
IS SHAPED AROUND ACTUAL NEED
RATHER TRYING TO FIT WHERE PEGS
INTO HOLES MORE ENGAGEMENT WITH
THE LATEST INDIGENOUS HEALERS
MEANT WHEN THEY NEED WHEN
NEEDED THERAPY SIR IS AVAILABLE
TO THOSE WHO WANT. SUPPORT FOR
EDUCATION TRAINING THAT
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF LIFE
WHICH IS THERE ARE OTHER
PROVIDERS FROM UNDER REPRESENT
COMMUNITIES. AND ONE THIRD SO
THREE BRING THIRTY OTHER CLINIC
IN INTO THE COMMUNITY WHICH
GREATLY. ENGAGEMENT AND SUCCESS.
WE ALSO NEED SUPPORT EXPRESSIVE
ARTS SPORTS COMMUNITY GO SMITE
AS PRACTICE RESTORED IS IN
SUPPORT OF ORGANIZATION YOU
THOUGHT I RISE IN OTHERS HE
TODAY I AM FROM. SCRATCH THREE
FRIENDS THAT CAN YOU. THE. WE
SERVE AND FINALLY WE CAN ASK
THAT ARE ALL AN OPEN TO LEARN
FROM THE EXPERTS AND WILLING TO
USE OUR POWER AND PRIVILEGE.
AND DISMANTLE UPON THE STEMS
AND IT TEACHES THAT. IMPACT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SEPTEMBER
WICKS AND STAFF FOR PUTTING ON
THIS VERY IMPORTANT TOPIC ALL
YOU WHO HAVE ARE HERE TO-
HEREIN ARE ALSO EXPRESSING YOUR
OWN FEAR THANK YOU IN HERE
WELL. MY COLLEAGUES YOU. JUST
ECHO EVERYTHING THEY SAID COME
DOWN. REESE BURNETT THE THIRD
HEY HOW. NATHAN SNYDER. EVAN
JOHNSON. ROBERT IN RE GET AS
ARTURO VIA VILLA NAVAL MIKE SAY.
JIMMY DIMITRIUS ANDRE BREA
BRIAN THESE ARE THE SHOW IS
THAT I STAND ON. THESE ARE
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE EITHER NOT
WITH US ANYMORE. OR THE BY GUN
VIOLENCE. MY NAME'S GAMES BACK
I AM THE POP THE DIRECTOR FOR
PUBLIC ADVOCATES- IN FOR OVER
TWENTY YEARS OUR ORGANIZATION
HAS PROMOTED HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES YES ON A LIMB
GETTING HELP TO SEE THESE BY
CHANCE FOR THE NEIGHBORHOOD TO
PLACES THAT NURTURE WELL BEING
OF ALL IN THE POLLS BUT
PARTICULARLY. THOSE TWO ARE.
ALLIES AND THOSE OF COLOR. THE
BLUES BAR MISSION TO SPAIN B.
I. N. AND CREATE A POLICY THAT
MAKES HELLO AND HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES BALADI ALL LOCAL.
WHAT THAT ALLIANCE IS A PUBLIC
HEALTH GREAT MAC. AND. AS WE'VE
HEARD EARLIER VIOLENCE IS OVER
WHAT CAUSED THE DEATH FOR
AFRICAN AMERICAN LATINO. AGES
FIFTEEN TO. AND IN MANY CITY
CALIFORNIA AND THE NATION
VIOLENCE IS THE LEADING KILLER
UNDER TWENTY FOUR IS ALL. THE.
VIA PRIVATE DISEASE SUCH AS
HEART DISEASE CANCER IS ACT AS
AS WELL AS MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
LIKE. THE DEPRESSION MANNING
EDDIE. PRIEST EXPO ISLANDS LOOK
TODAY QUALITY. YES. A PERSON'S
RISK OF A DOCTOR. YOUR
THEMSELVES MEANING THAT BY AND
SUBMIT AND IT'S BASED ON
EXPOSURE LIKE IT. THIS IS. I
KNOW THIS MAN FOR OVER TEN
YEARS. LEE WITH FAMILIES MOST
AFFECTED GUN VIOLENCE. SPENDING
INTIMATE TIME WITH. HAVE BEEN
SHOT AND HELPING THEM NAVIGATE
NOT. THE GOAL HEALING BUT
ALMOST MORE IMPORTANTLY EMMETT.
WELL IN THE IS WOULD FADE AWAY
BUT THE MINUTE. THEY HAD
EXPERIENCE. IT IS A MAJOR. GUN
VIOLENCE IN MINT HEALTH EIGHTY
THEN MEAN JUST SLIPPED IN THE
KEEPS YOU SAFE WELL WITH. WASTE
LEADING. AND STARDOM SORRY TO
STOP. IN THE STREET HOW TO
BREAK. BUT QUICK HOW DO YOU.
THAT AS WE LISTEN TO THE BOMB
TALK ABOUT HER. HER SIDE OF
BEING KILLED. I'M SIMPLY SEE
THINGS STORIES OF SURVIVORS.
FOR YES. WORKING IN THE STORE
OF SURVIVORS. ON THIS TO ME.
ACE AND HAVE. SHOOTERS. THOSE
WHO WERE ON THEIR WAY TO THE
CAUSING PERPETRATING ISLAND S.
B. CAN HAVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
THEM SO WE CAN SEE HERE IT. IS
THE POST WITH. THANK YOU. GOOD
EVENING MY NAME IS ANDREA AND
THE POLICY ADVOCATE FOR CAL IS
RISKY AND JUSTICE WE REPRESENT
ABOUT EIGHT OUT WE REPRESENT
HOUSE REVIVER. READ JUST THIS
VOICE TO ME IT. IS I CANCEL
JOSHUA DICK DICKERSON IS TO. I
WOKE UP I MYSELF. BECAUSE WE
HANG OUT IN THE PARK YEAH CAN
POSE BASKET BECAUSE WE AIN'T
BODY WASH MY UNIFORM RUSHED
INTO DARK IS THE SAME. MY BABY
SISTER AS MY HOME GOT IT ONE
TIME ADD TO EAT AS A GOOD. AND
ONE OF THE CLASS THE TEACHER
FIRST THANK GOD NO PENCIL. I
THINK WE WILL ONLY TALK I WILL
TELL YOU ACTUALLY WAS SOMEWHERE
ELSE AND YOU CAN SEE THAT MY- I
AM I AM A COMPLETELY UP. TO YOU
BE HERE- SO THANK YOU SOMEONE
NUMBER WORKS BUT ALSO MUNCIE
SOCIAL JUSTICE WARRIORS- WILL.
SAY THAT I CHANGE MY TEN. A I
WOULD GET IT. STATE GOVERNMENT
AND HOW WE CAN ALL IMPACT
CHANGE- EVEN IF ZACK RIGHT NOW-
BUT ONE THING STRUCK ME FOR THE
CONVERSATION. PANELISTS ALL OF
IT IT WAS SO HEARTWARMING TO
SEE SO MANY INDIVIDUALS WHO
DECATUR THEIR TIME TO SUPPORT
THOSE WHO WERE IMPACTED BY
VIOLENCE THE ONE PIECE OF THE
PIE THAT WAS MISSING FROM THE
ENTIRE CONVERSATION WAS
IMPLICIT BIAS. WE HAD SEVERAL
BILLS THAT ARE DUE THE
LEGISLATURE OVER THE PAST YEAR
TALKING ABOUT IMPLICIT BIAS
COMES TO HELP. EDUCATION AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT WHAT IS
IMPLICIT BIAS IT'S
AUTOMATICALLY LOOKING AT
SOMEONE. BUILDING THE THEIR
NARRATIVE IN YOUR OWN HEAD
RIGHT. AND SO WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT MONEY AND WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT. NEED TO DISCUSS FUNDING.
TO TALK DOLLARS AND SENSE
PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO HAVE THIS
RESOLUTION. DID WE NEED TO
RETRAIN OUR HEALTH CARE. WE
RETAIN OUR TEACHER WE NEED IN
OUR- OFFICERS AND WITH PEOPLE
WHO ARE CONSTANTLY BEING
VICTIMIZED AND- MY TIES. TO DAY
WE ARE REALLY TO BE A PARTNER.
WITH CALIFORNIA CHILDREN THIS
ONE. AS WELL AS UNITED WAY
FORMULA WITH AB EIGHT SEVEN
FIVE WE THINK THAT IS GOING TO
MAKE YOU MEET AND OUR STUDENTS
ON CAMPUS- BUT WE ALSO TALK
ABOUT THE VICIOUS CYCLE OF
CRIME THE AND WHOSE EARLIER
ABOUT HIS. REACTION WITH GANG
VIOLENCE HE IS PROBABLY. OUT OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE ABLE TO LOOK
INTUITIONS AND- NOW I WANT LIFE
TO GO TO THE BATHROOM THOSE WHO
WERE IMPACTED BY THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM AT. POINT THE 70% CHANGE
IMPACT. OUR SYSTEM SO WE REALLY
NEED TO BE MINDFUL OF. I JUST
HOW WE ARE DEALING WITH PEOPLE
WITH COMING TO SEEK SERVICE BUT
ALSO THERE- POTENTIALLY WHEN
THEY COME AND THEY ARE ALREADY
SEVERELY IMPACTED BY THE CYCLES
OF. THE THIRD THING I WANT
ABOUT IS REALLY. IMPORTANT
THING. BUT THIS IS TALK ABOUT
WHAT NEEDS HELP AND- I'LL TELL
YOU ONE FINDING IS A MAJOR
ISSUE IN THE STATE AS TO WHAT
WHAT WHAT ARE. THESE BOTH CAL.
AND IMPORT AND BEFORE HIM
OPERATE YES EMERGENCY SERVICES
THINK OF HOW DAVE MONITOR BIT
PURSES AND IT BUT YET ARE
LOOKED AFTER YEAR YEAR AND A
FIGHT SO THESE ARE CONVERSATION
NOT ONLY NEED TO BE LOCALS BUT
OUR STATE ELECTED BUT ALSO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AS TO WHY IN
ORDER. AGENCY THAT CORRECTLY
DID YOU FIND. DIRECTLY HERE TO
SUPPORT SURVIVORS IS BEING ON
FIND. EACH AND EVERY YEAR- THE
PAST AT AT IT ABOUT LIKE HOW
THE TV. THE WE TALK ABOUT TOM.
EACH PATIENT WE HAVE. BLACK AND
COMMUTE WHO DO NOT EVEN GO TO
SEE. ONE THEY DON'T KNOW ABOUT
IT IS ACTIVELY TOLD WHAT MRS
BAILABLE TO THOSE IN THE
COMMUNITY AND- A LOT OF IT. AT
THE SERVICES HOW'S THE T. A.'S
OFFICES IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICES THERE ARE A LOT OF THIS
IS WHERE PEOPLE DO NOT SEEK
PROCESS BECAUSE- RIGHT NOW. IN
STATUTE IF YOU DO NOT COOPERATE
WITH LINE FOR. YOU CAN I GET
APPROVED FOR BIG. THAT IS NOT A
CARROT BEING HUNG OVER PEOPLE'S
HEADS ALREADY I'M A TIGHT BY
THOSE WITH THE LOST I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE HELL WHAT WHAT
DID YOU. THE VICTIM WILL NOT
HAVE BLACK. THEY HAVE TO
TESTIFY AGAINST WERE IN THEIR
NEIGHBORHOOD SURE THEIR NAME
CATCH. THEN COSTS HAVE GONE
DOWN. YEAH THE. WHERE DID YOU
HAVE IN YOUR NEIGHBOR CHILDREN
AT HOME OR YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
THERE FOR YOUR CHILDREN TO
RECEIVE SERVICES THAT IS
ESSENTIALLY THE CYCLE OF CRIME
IMPACT IN. RE CRIMINAL NATION
OF THOSE WHO ARE IMPACTED.
VIOLENT CRIME. I HAVE TO REALLY
LOOK IN THE MIRROR A LOT.
OPTIONAL. TO BE ABLE TO TALK TO
INDIVIDUALS AND TELL THEM TO.
WE HAVE TO AND FOR THE PEOPLE.
IS THAT THE USER NAME CHANGE
PLEASE WHILE. I JUST WANT YOU
AGAIN. I TELL EVERYONE. UP HERE
I'M AND WE A CALIFORNIA
RECEIVED IN JUST WOULD LOVE TO
TALK TO ALL THE DOCK HERE ON
THAT PREVIOUS PANEL BECAUSE WE
REALLY NEED TESTIMONY I'M NOT
WE HAVE A STORE BUT WE ALSO
KNOW HOW THAT IMPACTS OF.
COMMUNITIES AND WE NEED A LOT
OF THAT DATA SO I WILL PROBABLY
BE REACHING A LOT OF YOUTH.
HELLO. I JUST LIKE TO SAY THANK
YOU AND RECOGNIZE MY FELLOW
PANELISTS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS. HI MY NAME IS OUT ON
THE FRONT OF THE CALIFORNIA
TERMS- HAVE PERSON TO BUILD
PROBABLY A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS. THE KID AND THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THE CHILDREN I
SERVED IN THE OAKLAND UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN A LEVEL ONE
PEDIATRIC TRAUMA CENTER IN
JUVENILE DETENTION AND WELFARE.
WEREN'T TRICKLE. WHAT TYPE
STUFF. BUT EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THEM. FROM THE PROGRAMS
ADMINISTERED EXTRA PROVIDED AS
A THERAPIST TO BE DIAGNOSED.
YOU HAVE TO RECEIVE FALLEN G.
SOMEONE OF A DIFFERENT RACE IN
A DIFFERENT CLASS. THE MENTAL
CHALLENGE THE SYSTEM IN A VERY
SMALL SMALL NUMBER OF YOUNG
PEOPLE THAT ACTUALLY GET SERVED
HAS TO BE ARRESTED NAMED. IT
HAS TO BE PUT IN TEXT. OF A
HOUSTON A HEALTH CRISIS THAT
HAS BEEN FOUR HUNDRED YEARS IN
THE MAKING. IT'S S. WE
CONSTRUCTED EPIDEMIC DESPAIR
SLATE IS. AND DIFFERENT NOW AND
EVEN WHEN I WORKED AT OAKLAND
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
FORTUNES HOSPITAL EARLY TWO
THOUSANDS. BETWEEN OFFERING IT
THIS WAY. WHAT WAS THE MOST
PROSPEROUS NATION IN THE
HISTORY OF THE WORLD TOO WHEN
THEY WAKE UP ONE MORNING AND
FIND THAT TWICE AS MANY OF THE
ACTUAL. KILLING SELVES. BETWEEN
TWO THOUSAND SIX IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE NUMBER OF
CHILDREN PRESENTED EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS IN CALIFORNIA FOR
SUICIDE ATTEMPT INCREASED
DRIVEN 4% BY THE NUMBER OF WHAT
WE CALL BUT THAT'S LENGTH OF
DAY. THE LENGTH OF STAY IN ALL
HOSPITALS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
DECREASE BY 35% FOR ALL THIS
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF P. MENTAL
HELP. WERE INCREASED PERCENT.
WAS MEANT IS THREE SIX MILLION
OF CUP IS TEN MILLION CHILDREN.
ARE ENROLLED IN MEDICARE. LESS
THAN 5% RECEIVED ANYTHING LAST
YEAR IT IS ACCURATE. TO
CHARACTERIZE WHEN USED. ADD A
COMMENT SYSTEM THIS WAY MORE
IT'S GETTING THOSE WHO DO GET
IT. AND THE WRONG KIND.
CALIFORNIA IS ON THE OF
ATTEMPTING TO ADDRESS THE
CHALLENGE. TRUE THAT RACIST
CULTURE STRIP. PRESS. AS TODAY
INCREMENTALISM HIS PART SHIN.
CALIFORNIA HAS THE LEAST
EXPECTED IN ITS RECENT CALLAHAN
PRO WHICH IS A PROPOSAL TO
FUNDAMENTALLY REFORM MEDICAID.
NO SIR SHOULD BE REMOVED AS AN
EBELING. CONDITION THANK YOU PS
REIMBURSEMENT. IS IN A CRITICAL
MORE TOWARDS CREATING MORE JUST
AND EQUITABLE SYSTEM BUT IT IS
ONE OF ONLY THREE THINGS I'LL
NAME IN MY LAST MINUTE. THE
FIRST THING WE MUST DO FORM OF
MEDICAID IS DRAMATIC EXPAND.
THE STATE'S. TRACK FORTY SECOND
THE NATION AND SPENDING PER
CHILD. THE HIGHEST TAX BASE IN
THE NATION. SO THE OPERATOR HER
EARLIER ABOUT VICTIMS OF THEM
SHOULD BE. NOT MORE POLITE TO A
MEDICAID PROGRAM. SURE CHARLIE
BROWN CHRISTMAS TREE WITH A
MAGICAL CHRISTMAS TREE
ORNAMENTS HUNG UP. SIXTY THREE
POP SIXTY FOUR PROP TO. FIFTY
STAND PUBLIC FINANCE. SECOND WE
MUST WE FIND THE BENEFIT SO
PLACES LIKE RIGHT THE FUNDING.
I SHOULDN'T HAVE TO HAVE A
DIAGNOSIS AND YOU SHOULD HAVE
TO BE A CLINICIAN WHAT WE KNOW.
IS THIS HUMAN CONNECTION.
CONNECTION OTHER PEOPLE WITH
COMMON LIVED EXPERIENCE. AND WE
KNOW THIS LOOK AT THE RECORD.
TODAY TONIGHT TWENTY MILLION
PEOPLE ACROSS THIS NATION WILL
GET TOGETHER WITH NO CLINICIAN
IN THE ROOM. ONLY BY THEIR
COMICS TO SUFFERING AND MAGIC
WILL HAPPEN. WHERE IS THE
RECOVERY MOVEMENT FOR BEING
BROUGHT A BLACK ICON FOR BEING
A NEW MOM FOR BEING A NEW COMER
FOR HAVING YOUR FIRST JOB.
PEOPLE CAN SOLVE THEIR OWN
PROBLEMS GIVEN. SURE. AND CAN
ACTIVITY TO SELL. FIVE DRESS
ARE ARE. PUBLIC SYSTEM. THE
SOMETIMES EVEN OUT OF GOOD
INTENTIONS PATRICK. AND
DISCONNECTION. SO ONE WAY TO
THINK OF THE OPPORTUNITY IN
FRONT OF US AND- USE MEDIC. TIE
THAT BINDS OUR FORM BY
EXPANDING RESOURCES CHANGING
THE BENEFIT AND RESTRUCTURING
PUBLIC SYSTEMS. PRETTY POWERFUL
PANEL GUYS. THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH A COUPLE TIMES AND WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO A PUBLIC COMMENT
FOR FOLKS BUT. DO YOU BLOW YOU
SAID SOMETHING THAT STRUCK ME
YOU SAID HOW DO WE HEAL THE
ROUTE. CAN YOU ELABORATE ON
WHAT THAT TANGIBLE PUBLIC.
SOLUTION IS AND I DON'T THERE'S
PROBABLY A LOT THAT QUESTION
RIGHT I MEAN. WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT SYSTEMATIC ISSUES AROUND
RACIAL INEQUITIES IN EDUCATION
AND ARE MISSING POLICY AND YOU
KNOW OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM IN THERE SO MUCH WRAPPED
UP INTO THAT. BUT I'D LOVE FOR
YOU TO EXPAND ON THAT THOUGHT.
THAT'S A LOADED QUESTION. I'M
THIRTY. WE WILL BE ANSWERED
THIRTY SECONDS DONE SURE OKAY
IS. WELL WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE.
AND WE AS WELL AS THE POWERS
THAT BE NEED TO RECOGNIZE THAT.
EVERY SYSTEM IN AMERICA HELLO.
EVERY SYSTEM IN AMERICA IS
PROPPED UP ON THE DEAD WHITE
MEN AND- COOL IT NEEDS A
SERIOUS- HALL- I DON'T HAVE THE
ANSWERS TO HOW THAT WORKS BUT
IT IT DOES BEGAN WITH
COURAGEOUS CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE SAME THERE IS AN SENATORS
IN A ROOM TOGETHER FIGHTING FOR
OUR PEOPLE. I'VE BEEN DOING
THIS FOR A VERY LONG TIME AND I
KNOW THAT WE ARE AFRAID TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THOSE WHO
ARE MOST HEARD BECAUSE. WE FEEL
OUR FEET THEY'RE BEING POINTED
BACK AT THAT WELL. WE ARE THE
CALLS AT TIMES. AND
SPECIFICALLY OUR INDIVIDUAL SET
UP THE SYSTEMS ARE ALL SET SO
WE NEED TO TAKE. ALL TO BE TO
COME TOGETHER AND HAVE REAL
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT WHAT CHANGE
REALLY YEAH AND HAVE THE SUN
COMES PER SE. YEAH YEAH THANK.
I'M IN YOU ALL I THINK BROUGHT
A VERY POIGNANT IMPORTANT
EQUITY LANDS TO THE NATION-
SHOULD MAKE A YOU MENTIONED THE
NEED TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE A
CALL AND SEE IF. IT'LL HELP
DELIVER STUFF. GET THE EQUITY
ISSUES WHAT DO YOU THINK IT'S
LIKE. THIRTY SECONDS APART AS
WELL BUT I MEAN I THINK OUT TO
THE FINAL POINTS WHICH ARE.
TRYING TO MAKE AND I THINK YOU
HEARD THE OTHER CONVERSATIONS
WHICH IS WHAT'S CLUED. PLACE
MOST ACT IN INFORMATION. NEEDED
TO MAKE SURE THAT FAMILIES
ACTUALLY GET ACCESS INFORMATION
AND SERVICES AND WHAT WE NEED
TO BE THING IS THINKING ABOUT.
THOSE DOLLARS TO BREAK THAT
DOWN. SO THAT WE'RE MEETING.
OUR IN. THINKING AND IMAGINING
WHAT THE DEFINITION OF CALL. I
GET DOESN'T NECESSARILY NEED TO
BE IN A HOSPITAL SETTING- BUT
IT CAN BE HEALING CENTER AND
COMMUNITY BASED AND SO I THINK
THAT IS THE- FIRST STEP. IS
BEING ABLE TO FORWARD IN. IF
THAT. WELL I WELCOME ALL OF
YOU- TO CONVERSATIONS ON. OR
NOT- IN MY PURVIEW IN THIS- AS
HE IS. FROM THE AREA AND I VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE ESTIMATES SAY
SO THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH.
PROVIDE HELLO SHOULD. KEEP
THERE COMMENTS LAST. PLEASE
GIVE YOUR NAME AND I'LL BE HI
IT'S OKAY JUST JUST COME DOWN
HERE TO THE ISLANDS HEAR PUBLIC
COMMENT. TO HEAR ME. FIRST
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS SOMEONE
FOR FREE AS PANEL MY NAME STATE.
I AM THE RIGHT THE RIGHT PATH.
OR FROM CO. WE DO MOST OF OUR
WORK AND THE CAT ALL. I REALLY
WANT. IN ALL THE PANEL MEMBERS
AND THE AUDIENCE THERE IS A
HEARING AT THE STATE CAPITOL ON
IT WAS. THE RIGHT WAY IT HAS TO.
SHIN SIXTY THREE OR THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT THERE IS A
LOT OF MONEY PEOPLE WERE
TALKING ABOUT ME. THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES THAT IS GREAT
FOR A LOT OF MONEY. THINKING OF
RE DESIGN. NO I'M NOT I THINK
IT SHOULD BE READ AS A. LET ME
TELL YOU I THINK I WILL NOT
YIELD OF BECAUSE I'M VERY US
ABOUT THE KIND OF BECAUSE
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT. AND THE
WORK IS VERY HARD I WAS. FIRED
BY THE PANEL IN FACT YEAH THANK
YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS CHARLENE
HARR AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF HEALING CIRCLES OF
HOPE. HEY I WANT TO BE AND LAST
COUPLE WEEKS OR LAST MONTH WHEN
WE TRAVEL TIME BECAUSE I LOST
TO YOU THERE USED TO BE IN A
FORM OF PROGRAM ONE IS THAT SHE
HAD A SHE- THAT KILLED UP AT
THE MANSION PARTY. AND ANOTHER
ONE IS A YOUNG AND IT JUST GOT
KILLED LAST WEEK HE. YEAH I
LIKE ON. IT IS LIKE THEY LIVE
IN ISOLATED. ONE OF MY SEPTUM
I'M GIVEN A HOLIDAY PARTY SONG
AND I WAS TOLD IT BYE BYE ANY
OF THEM. I COME IN AND SHUT IT
DOWN REALLY HAVE MY HEART.
BECAUSE THOSE KEY IN ON. A
LITTLE. TWELVE BEST FRIEND SO
THEY LOST THEIR CHILDREN ALL IN
THIS. JUST IMAGINE THAT I KNOW
GRANDMOTHER OUT. WHEN. THE
NEIGHBORHOOD OF RICHMOND AND
RICHMOND SAN PABLO MIGHT RETAIN
AND I'LL HAVE A LOSS BUT YOU'RE
ABOUT DIDN'T DIE. DISS ME SAW
WHAT. TO A SUPPORT GROUP CALLED
WOMEN IS THE IS THE- IS A-
GROUP BUT I FEEL COMFORTABLE
THERE. I GO FOR MY. AND THEN I
GOT ONE SON THAT HAS TO HELP US
IMPROVE THIS IN JAIL EVERY. NOT.
IT'S NOT GONNA STOP DOING WHAT
IS MEANT. YEAH THANK. LAST
MONDAY IT WAS BAD I GOT UP LAST
NIGHT SO WHERE DO I FIND HELP
HIM AND SO ON I'M MAD ABOUT THE
RISE OF I'VE I'VE- WORKED. SIX
FAMILIES WHO LIVE INCLUDING MY
GRANDMA MY BOARD MEMBERS WHOSE.
UP LAST WEEK. YEAH I SHOT. IN
THE SLOT ALL THE CHILDREN ALL
THE CHILDREN IN THE- RIGHT.
LIKE ALL LIES AND HELPFUL I'M
GLAD IT AT SO I'M GLAD TO SAY
WHAT I SAID THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AT FIFTEEN CENTS FOR
BILL SIGNED BY I'LL HAVE IT
SENT UP AN OFFICE IN ONE OF
THEM WAS. AND I DO HAVE TO BE
TWENTY ONE YEARS NOW PURCHASE
IT. AND WE'RE HOPING TO THE
UNIVERSAL BACKGROUND CHECK PAT
WE WHAT TO DO BE ON NATIONAL
DAY OF REMEMBRANCE WERE
ENMESHED MCCONNELL'S OFFICE. A
HUNDRED OF US HE WOULD.
CONGRESSWOMAN LOOSEN BACK AND
CALM WITH MEN JOHN EVIDENT HE
DID NOT COME OUT. IT IS A IT
OUT AND WE DO NOT OFFER SOMEONE
WAS TELLING US. ONE PARTY WAS
SUPER S. H. R. EIGHT UNIVERSAL
BACKGROUND CHECKS I WANT YOU
ALL KNOW THAT WE WILL BE HAVING
A GUN BUY BACK THIS ALL NIGHT
THEN WE WILL GO MY BACK IS A
CISCO ALMOND REASON WHY WE DO
IT BECAUSE THIS IS THE HIGHEST
WE DO NOT THE FOURTEENTH
BECAUSE AS FIRST OF ALL THE
ANNIVERSARY NEW TOWN- AND
FOLLOW THE GUN BUY BACK WE WILL
BE. HAVING THE. ISSUE AT THEIR
BAPTIST CHURCH. IN EVERY. SIDE
OF VIOLENCE WITH A- AND THE
REASON WHY WE DO IT. ONE IN THE
HOME. TO HAVE GUNS MAKE A LEFT
ON LOCKER LOADED ON IT AT. A
HUNDRED AMERICANS WERE KILLED
WITH GUNS AND THREE THE
PRESENCE OF A GUN AND THAT THE
BOMB IS SITUATED IS INCREASES
THE REST OF. THE WEAPON BEING
KILLED LIKELY FIVE TIMES. AS 2%
A FIREARM RELATED DEATHS AND
NOT AS A SUICIDE. AND THE
RECENT OF. SHOOTING THAT THAT
THE MATCH THE YOUNG MAN THERE
ARE SEPSIS GO THIS WAS THAT
PART THE THIRD SON ON ANOTHER
MOTHER VERY WELL AND- THEY WILL
BE WITH US ON. THE VISUAL. IS
VERY. WHEN MOTHERS AND WE DO
PHILIP NICHOLS. OF THE OF THE
SOUL I'M- OUT MINUS SEVEN CISCO
ONLY HAVE RESOURCES THAT WE
TEACH THEM WILL SHOW YOU HOW TO
YOUR HOUSE AND COME TO YOUR
TRIP TO EUROPE WHO JUST HOW DID
IT OUR GOALS WERE FIRST
RESPONSE. AS WELL FRANCISCO.
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND I HOPE THAT ON YOU I HAVE
CARDS TO GET THE RIGHT AND SO
THE RIGHT PEOPLE AND LOCAL
THERE WHATSOEVER YOU WILL GET
THE MONEY FOR THE GUN WHAT THE
OUT OF THE OUT OF THE HANDS IT
DOES IN THE HOME. DOES THE
QUESTIONS THAT ALSO EVER SO I
HAVE IT IN THE CAR SO IF YOU
HAVE EMAILED A GLAD TO SEE YOU
THE COMMISSION AS WELL BY EMAIL
BUT I WILL GO TO SICK BECAUSE
OF THE WRONG HANDS TO GET
MYSELF A STREET ON THIS HOLIDAY
SEASON. THANK YOU. VERY MUCH.
ANY OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE
COME DOWN TO THE AISLE IF YOU
WANT TO PROVIDE ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT. GOOD AFTERNOON OR GOOD
AT THIS GOOD EVENING US A
MEMBER BUT HE WORKS MY NAME'S
SHARI'S ARRIVING FROM THE
DEVELOPER ASSOCIATION. I THANK
ALL THE PANELISTS THAT HAD
LIVED EXPERIENCES THAT WERE
SPEAKING A- TEXT ONLY POWERFUL
TEST. WITH THAT BEING MADE MORE
POWERFUL STATE LEGISLATOR IN
CONVERSATION NOW. I'M IN SO I
JUST REALLY WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR HOLDING THIS PANEL AND ALSO
IS. YOU KNOW ESPECIALLY WITH
MASS SHOOTING HAPPENED AFFECT
YOU NEED TO CALL THE SCHOOLS.
OFTEN TIMES IT IMMEDIATE IT'S
INDIVIDUAL WITH YOUR. UNTIL
THAT ARE ON THE VICTIMS SIDE
MEDIAN I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT
THE YOU KNOW THESE. WELL THAT
STUFF ABOUT GUN VIOLENCE. HI
SCRUTINIZE MEDIAN SO OFTEN IN
THE MEDIA THESE INDIVIDUALS NOT
ONLY NEED SINCE BUT THEY ALSO
NEED TO BE UNDERSTOOD ALSO BE
YOU KNOW IN THE SITUATION IT
CAN BE. HARMFUL SEVEN. THANK
YOU. I WOULD LIKE. TO COME UP
AND ALSO ABOUT THE MY NAME IS
IT. I AM A MEMBER TEENS ON
TARGET. FULL OF MY COLLEAGUE
GREG I WOULD LIKE TO THINK OF
ALL THE PET. TO BEING. IMPOSED
ON THIS PAGE WE NEED. HAS COME
FROM MY COMMUNITY THIS IS LIKE
A HUGE ISSUE FOR US AND THAT
PEOPLE ACTUALLY WORKING HELP
PREVENT DISEASE. IT REALLY
MAKES ME LAUGH. I WOULD LIKE TO
THINK OF. PUBLIC COMMENT. WELL
JUST WANT TO THANK EVERYONE.
AND IF YOU'RE IN FOR. A LITTLE
HEAVY RIGHT. BUT A LOT OF HOPE
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE A LOT OF
REALLY SMART PEOPLE IN THIS
ROOM AND OTHER PLACES AT THE
NEED TO END OUR OF IMAGE OF GOD
BUT ALSO ENSURE THAT- THOSE
THAT ARE IMPACTED BY GUNMEN
HAVE THE ACCESS TO THE BEHAVIOR
OF THE MENTAL THREE THAT THEY
NEED SO THAT WE CAN STOP.
ALLIANCE I'M I'M- THIS IS. WITH
ALL SHOULD ALL PENDING TODAY TO
LOOK FOR THE FOR THE
CONVERSATION CONVERSATION SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH